Swap.
Hey.
You threw me off the groove.
I was like, you're not supposed to talk back.
I'm here too!
Hello guys.
Okay, so you guys might see like this little...
Sorry, I looped the intro because like Min and I were
sharing secrets.
We were sharing secrets.
You're not invited.
They're really good secrets.
Yeah.
If only you could have heard what we said you'll never know
you're gonna miss the foam oh wait no wouldn't they want the
foam or they have you have foam oh you have foam what could
we have said oh my god within like five minutes i'm gonna
tell them right now all right say it
Because it's about you so you it's your secret anyway.
Wait, don't you tell me stuff too?
But the later half was your secret.
Yeah, first half was Doki secrets and then yeah, it was my
secret.
Yeah, so there's two secrets that you don't know Two whole
secrets oh my god two whole secrets that you were not there
for how long are we gonna drive?
We gotta give them all the FOMO.
Yeah.
Now that we're in these, we don't have to deal with FOMO
anymore.
So we give you FOMO instead.
We give you FOMO.
We can do whatever we want.
Yeah.
Okay, so if you guys don't see the bottom right, text on my
end I don't know if you're showing it mint oh I can move
myself warning this version may cause the game to crash so
it's not our PC it might be a kuso game I don't know yeah it
might be it might be this is your decision yeah I suggested
the game okay so um so this game I told mint that she has to
start a new game herself as well.
So, like, because I, because there's an intro to the game.
So don't click multiplayer, right?
Click new game.
Don't click, just do new game.
And then you do normal.
And then you'll be met with, like, an intro.
Anyway, so those who don't know what Hospital 666 is, it's
basically like that, was it Platform 8?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it's basically Platform 8, but, or Exit 8.
Sorry, Exit 8.
It's basically Exit 8, But what if we added multiplayer in
there?
How do you even do that?
I don't even know.
I don't know.
We're going to find out now.
I wonder if it's like 666 floors.
There's 666.
How long is this?
How long?
We're going to be playing up until Doki's new model, you
guys.
Yeah, yeah.
Into the new skin suit.
Yeah.
This is 24 hours, by the way.
Surprise!
you know like the the spookies the jump scare mansion oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're gonna make it to floor a
thousand guys is that actually how long that game is no way
oh yeah the spookie you never played the jump scare one no
no oh yeah i think it is i think it's like uh i think it
it's i played it before it's up to like a thousand floors
and because like every and then because every hundred you
get it's like a new like a new new theme to the to the like
rooms and stuff so it gets spookier and spookier okay um and
at one point one of them was like uh one of the at one point
you go to a floor that's just a fucking maze someone's at a
thousand floors plus bonus dlc floors they made more floors
no it's oh wait yeah they made more floors yeah there's dlc
floors too and there's like and then like and then you get
taken to like a hospital too it's like hospital six hospital
yeah oh yeah and then i also uh while we were like waiting
for the stream um i linked mint a really good
i linked i linked mint a vtuber background and i was like oh
my god it's perfect it's so it's the best it's actually i
should have used it today man That's what you should have.
No, that's what they want.
That's what the Wisp won.
That background?
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm going to link it to my chat.
It's this one, guys.
We...
I'll link it to my chat, too.
And then you being like, you can recreate that Dr. Horrible
seal.
Bro, everybody loves it.
Helping that random girl you see at the laundromat roleplay.
It's like...
it's like the one of the top five cliches out there top five
dreams it's true you we could be that girl yeah oh my god
there's this there's this ghost made and that my laundromat
my laundromat's haunted oh spooky spooky because it was like
who wants this i was like what do you mean who what no no no
i said what led to them creating like what was the demand
like who said man i really need like a laundromat like she
saw he saw a random girl at the laundromat he's like well
that could be if only vtubers had this too not enough anime
start with a guy meeting a girl at the laundromat i'm
telling you he's like no he's like you know like we the west
version of weaboos like the west abu yeah the west abu's
it's i bet you the person created is a west abu they saw too
many like american tv shows where it starts off the laundry
he's a west boo he wishes japan has more of this i'm gonna
throw chat in the laundry machine i'm gonna throw you guys
in the perfect rp i would make it so that the chat is like
the laundry mats like overlaid on top of chat and then you
guys are spinning spinning in me i won't be doing it okay
i'll do it guys yeah yeah check mint channels out if you
want to uh live your laundromat fantasies wow see that's why
i linked you the background i knew you you knew it was made
for me i knew it was made for you this background's made for
you okay how's our volume by the way yeah after all that i'm
gonna start a new game yeah we're gonna start a new game too
you guys gotta see the intro do just do any difficulty yeah
any difficulty in and then we'll hook and then or do normal
yeah this is not game footage this is a real footage yeah
this is the dev what's going on oh my god he's so mad now
we're in the game
that was it yeah that was it that's what i wanted you to see
i was like what the fuck is this now you're in the game too
all these instructions they have like the entire world wait
is he a vtuber like yeah yeah he's apparently like um how
guys by the way guys this developer is single
so ladies and guys too wait should i turn v-sync on or off i
can't remember i don't know okay she asked me if she should
play on dx11 or go and she was like what what's the
difference i was like i don't know
turning it on helped me not lag so okay that's good i'm
returning to the menu all right also sound guy turned up
mint up a bit more is it better now blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah all right let me i'll invite you let me
go to multiplayer host because i don't did you start it off
on easy no i did normal okay i i couldn't tell because
you're like oops and i was like oh no what do you mean oops
all right how do i invite you Oh, give me a sec.
The friend's list is, like, empty for me.
Oh, okay.
This is fine.
That should be fine, right?
All right.
I can invite you to watch this game.
Wait, can you go to multiplayer and see if you find me in
the game?
No, you're not there.
I'm not there?
Okay, let me.
I have no friends.
Oh, okay.
No, I meant, like, you know how you go to multiplayer?
Do I show up on multiplayer?
No.
I don't?
No, what if I press host?
Oh.
Well, if you're hosting, then I can join.
Let me, I can join you.
Yeah, try me.
Try me.
Okay, give me a sound.
All right, return to menu.
Refresh.
Why don't you exist on my friends list?
See, that's what I'm saying.
Wait, can you invite me?
Uh.
Hello.
You guys, we're not professionals, okay?
We're indie VTubers, please.
You have to have zero expectations on us.
and we're indie vtubers please understand please understand
it is just us right now yeah we're not professionals we're
not we should not be put up to standards when it comes to
corporate vtubers we're just one person i say when i have a
team behind well i don't so i can actually it's just yeah
myself and i how do i invite okay hold on we're not even
okay here you go i i can invite to watch what i can watch
you i'm sorry i boosted her volume again sound guy how do i
join you all right oh guys we're give us a sec guys we
totally instead of you know we met up 15 minutes before the
stream started and instead of preparing the stream we were
sharing secrets we were
oh my god had a priority it was a juicy good secret yeah
yeah if you knew the secret you would have been like good
choice you know okay i'm gonna do friends i'm gonna change
my profile settings and see if you can invite me now okay
you see me on i think you see me on vtube studios instead of
hospital
Turn to the menu.
Yeah.
I'm going to multiplayer.
I'm going to host.
I'm going to host a game.
I don't think if you host it, you'll show up, right?
And then...
No, it should be, because, like, what's the point of hosting
it if you don't...
Like, what's the point of hosting it?
How did the other people...
No, there's no way other VTubers were able to set this up.
We can't be as...
We can't be stupider than other VTubers.
Like, yes, we can, Doki, yes, we can!
No, we can!
I think we're tougher than most people!
There's no way!
All VTubers have, like, almost equivalent IQ.
Wait, how do you add, or how do you invite someone on Steam?
I never remember.
Wait, wait, what?
That's what I was telling you to do!
How do I do that?
Shift tab!
tab nothing showed up oh okay just kidding just kidding okay
okay have you never done ship tab before okay now how do i
add you all right you see where where dokey bird is and then
you go to invite oh i can invite you to watch I was saying,
you can't even watch.
But it's not even watch the game, it's watch me, Bridger.
I mean, don't you want to watch my face?
The whole time?
The whole time, definitely.
We both have, like, a solo session of Hospital 666, and
we're just watching.
Like, we sync up our Hospital 666 game.
play together obviously we're like see who gets to the most
floors we can make it a competition i'm gonna restart my
game maybe it's not us maybe guys we need to play in dx mode
oh was it did we actually have to play in dx mode i don't
know oh i got an achievement for for leaving the game
okay we can do this guys we can have chat no it's good chat
you can we guys get more content we could have ended earlier
if we didn't have this i'm ending the stream right now okay
i'm hosting again okay hold on wait are you on dx i'm on
dx11 yeah okay i'm on the normal one so i don't know if that
affects anything oh okay can you see mine i see you i see
you oh my god was dx11 all of joining hopefully it doesn't
crash because it said that this version i'm in the floor
you're on the floor i don't see you no i'm in the floor oh
here wait you're in the floor where are you i hear noises i
hear you walking on top of you i think i hear you wait go
towards the man with the hat can i see you go towards the
man with the hat okay okay do you see me do you see me what
do you see i'm stuck in the floor i'm gonna i'm gonna leave
you i'm gonna go to the next floor yeah go to the Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, remember I said layout.
This is what it looks like.
Well, figure it out.
This is, okay.
This is a default.
Just figure it out then.
Figure it out.
Okay, okay.
All right, I'm gonna, I'll leave you.
Goodbye.
I see the doors closed.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, uh-oh.
Where are you?
I don't, I'm still stuck in the floor.
Are you on the next story?
I'm on the next story.
Did you come back?
I'm going up another floor and see if...
I'm gonna go back up another floor.
Are you still on the first floor?
I can't even exit to the menu.
Like, pressing escape does nothing.
I'm gonna...
I'm still on the second floor.
Okay, I'm leaving the game.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna start a new game.
Okay.
Okay, I'll join you.
I'll join you.
Maybe that'll work.
Okay, okay.
I'm not doing the DX.
I'm joining normal.
Okay, I'm hosting.
I'm hosting.
Okay.
All right, sound guy.
I turned down mint a little bit.
Is it better now?
We're still adjusting sound while figuring out how to play
this game.
It's okay.
We're in these guys.
We're in these.
Okay, can you see?
see me in the game okay no i don't see you in the game no i
do not okay um wait how did you see me maybe it was the dx
mode i'm telling you man i'll go i'll go on dx mode we'll
swap we'll just try hosting again and maybe maybe okay wait
no i'll do dx mode this is so great you guys guys guys we
are professionals this is all because we didn't even test it
because she was Like, you have to see the new game intro.
She's like...
That is not true.
We didn't test it because I showed her the laundromat.
Get it right.
Sorry, my bad.
You're right.
There's a sequence of events that led to this.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, are you in the game yet?
I'm in the game, yeah.
Okay, because I don't see you.
Oh, maybe it's because you're...
Are you like...
Oh, wait.
Hold on, hold on.
I'm hosting.
okay oh okay okay also i have another idea i think it's
because your steam is on you don't show what game you're
playing on steam so because like i've made mine friends only
so like you should make yours friends only and then after
the stream we private it how do you do that what you mean
you said you have that's okay you know what did you learn in
the last two three years like me what did you learn in the
last three years like what did you mean okay okay go to go
to steam click click your name yeah go to like your name go
to privacy settings hold on where is hold on wait under my
profile okay you go to yeah go to go to uh go to me i'm
gonna go to donkey Okay, go to edit profile.
Okay.
Oh, privacy setting.
And then friends only.
Oh, my God.
Miss playing hospital.
No way that actually fixed it.
Oh, my God.
I can see you now.
Come on.
Join the game.
Oh, there you are.
Oh, my God.
It was the steam thing all over again.
I can't believe you learned this as an indie.
I'm just getting my feet off the ground.
I've been around for two months.
Come on, give me a break.
You!
You existed, you existed five years ago.
You can't say that.
When I existed, you existed.
When we were both in these.
You can't say that.
Okay, you know what, Doki, you need to shave, okay?
Come on.
Come on, get out of my way.
I'm ready to get out of this hospital.
Oh, oh my gosh, did you hear that?
Can we open the door?
Yeah.
How do you open the door?
I don't think we can.
I don't think we're allowed to.
Okay, we got...
Oh, wait, that's us.
That's us.
That's our triplet.
We're visiting our triple at the hospital.
Solid, liquid, solid.
Yeah.
All right.
We gotta memorize this layout.
We gotta figure out what the anomalies are later.
Okay.
Look at that.
Wait.
I heard that there's like a thing I can do in multiplayer.
Can I do it?
Oh, I can.
What?
Yeah.
That's where you want to get beat up in the hospital.
Don't make me put the button!
I'm in here!
I'm in here too!
Slamming the button.
I'm gonna punch you in the balls.
That's what I'm gonna do.
Now I'm gonna punch you first.
Oh yeah!
Yeah!
Are you gonna make it to the elevator?
The first one there's running!
Yeah, push me back to the elevator.
Come on!
Where are you?
I know!
Whoa!
Give me a- No!
No!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
No, I can't!
You can't punch people in the elevator!
Yes, you can!
I'm punching your- I like how we are not checking the
anomalies.
We're back to floor zero.
Wait, what do you mean we're back to floor zero?
What happened?
Look at the elevator!
What do you mean?
What happened?
What are you- What are you- But we're advancing.
We played the game.
Oh!
Damn it, I can't leave you.
I haven't been near the floor.
I don't think there's any anomalies.
Wait, are you getting coffee?
Yeah.
Not for you.
Why get coffee when we can get gamer subs?
I saw it.
Anyway, guys.
Did you guys know that we both have gamer subs?
We both have ghosts.
Anyway, feel free to use a dokey bird for 10% off and only
dokey bird.
which is the cooler, more trendy code to use.
Or the link in the description.
Link in the description.
There's no link in your description.
Yes, there is, yes there is.
I'm getting to the elevator first.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
What?
Oh, we were, wait, you are, okay.
No, no, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think there's a nominee here.
You think so?
Yeah, I think so.
What is it?
I don't think there was too, psych.
You can't even press the button while you can't even go.
No, I can't sit here.
What's the point?
We have to find the anomaly.
Come on.
I don't know.
Everything looks the same.
Wait, isn't he on the other side?
He's the backboard.
No, he was always here.
No, because this is where we start off.
Because this is where you got coffee, remember?
Oh, you're right, you're right.
Yeah, and then you're like, go over here and you're like,
oh, there's all the medicine.
There's this beautiful vista.
All right, let me read the rules.
You find Anomaly, press the L.
Let me read the rules.
It's 30 minutes into this game.
We played this game for five minutes.
20 minutes of this game was text-support.
Okay, if you don't find the Anomaly, press a button from
the...
another elevator.
Oh, from the elevator over on this side.
So, we don't find the anomaly.
We just gotta... Oh, we come back here?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can use the top button to review the previous floor.
Orange light outside means you're starting from this
elevator.
Oh, okay, so it tells you, like, which elevator you start
from.
Wait, no, if you don't find an anomaly, press the button
from another... Oh, so, if we find an anomaly, we come here.
If we don't find an anomaly, we go over there.
It's wherever.
It's wherever elevator you start with.
Yeah.
Because both we go up a floor.
I don't think you're like or like we go if we find one we go
here if we don't find one we go down there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, we press the yeah, yeah.
No, it's just me because there's a restart.
There's a no.
No, that's if you want to go back to the previous floor.
Oh, we're guys see we can rain.
We okay.
Do you think there's anomaly?
No, I think so.
I think we're good.
right okay hold on there's five six doors two four six okay
one two three four five six okay that's what i said i don't
know i'm worried you couldn't count you know okay because
we're btubers they care about our health yeah there's like
lots of meds here guys remember to take your meds that's all
of dokey's meds right there that's yeah yeah yeah mids meds
in this room it's entire room dedicated to her okay okay
this one is so that she can count this one so she can read
this one i can't beat you up anymore what happened oh no i
need to take my meds i've lost control of my arms this one
is so my imaginary friend will finally disappear but i
didn't take it that's why it's all here why can't i punch
you all right let's just go up and see what Because I didn't
take my men.
Alright, we go.
We go up.
I think we're good.
It's gonna go to two.
It's gonna go to two?
Yeah.
It's not moving.
What the hell?
It's back to zero.
I knew we fucked it up.
There's no...
What did we mess up?
Okay, wait.
So this is zero so we can figure out what is all...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, so...
Water.
Okay, exit side.
The meds are still here.
Water?
Yeah.
Oh, there's two trash cans.
There's two fires.
Did you count it?
Yes, I counted the six doors.
I just wanted to be sure.
Okay, it's cafe cappuccino.
Cafe con...
What's it called?
Panah.
I think we go up the floor.
I think this is what Pacer Zero looks like.
Maybe the side.
Yeah, maybe the side.
One.
We can pay attention.
We are...
There's two of us.
Like, this is a map of, like, five people.
This is a one to four player game, okay?
It's not our fault we're missing two players.
to help us.
Was this always here?
Yeah, this was always here.
Okay.
I've seen this before.
And there was always, like, true...
Okay, alright.
Okay, then let's stay on this elevator.
Let's stay over here and press a button if you don't trust
me.
I mean the gas.
Oh!
Oh my god!
There's an anomaly!
What's the anomaly?
This guy is running!
What?
Oh my god!
Are you sure?
Wait, what do you mean sure do you not see it no he's he's
standing still wait actually yeah are you sure are you
gaslighting me i have photographic proof i'm glad i'm
streaming this a photo means that it's a photo it's a
snapshot a photo isn't animated that proves my No, chat.
I took my...
You guys, come on.
Believe me.
Come on.
Look at him.
He's running.
Yeah.
No, wait, Min's chat.
It's not running, right?
Min's chat.
It's not.
I don't see it.
I'm pretty sure on Earth.
I'm looking at stream right now.
It's not running.
Yes, yes.
You see him.
Use your eyes.
You forgot to take the meds to use your eyes.
I can only see it five frames per second.
Wait, so then that means we go to back to this one right we
go back and we like go up yeah okay yeah yeah yeah yeah so
like you know how like you know how like some camera like
some video cameras can move certain frames and then uh so
like you can actually have like a video of like a bird whose
wings are just like yeah yeah yeah yeah those are my eyes
right okay i think you need to get help for that oh we're at
two that was me we didn't we did not do anything i did it
together This is a team game.
It's a collab.
What you accomplish is what I can accomplish.
Oh my god, and now he's green.
He's not running at all.
I am looking at the calendar.
Medical center first.
Everything looks the same.
Yeah.
You know what?
I think you know who...
Wait!
There's three clocks!
Oh, there's...
Wait, wasn't there always three clocks?
one before maybe that was the anomaly wait maybe oh i think
it is three o'clock is the anomaly yeah i think so up from
here yeah see we're doing so good teamwork we we're doing so
good guys i think you know what you know what who can be our
third and fourth player chat yeah how true oh see yeah one
clock one clock oh my god I think we're really good at this
game.
This game is too easy.
Yeah, this game is weird.
It's not like we fucked up like three times before we
figured it out.
The royal we.
Yeah, sure.
I don't think there's any anomalies this time.
It doesn't look like it.
Well, you said that last time and there were three clocks.
Look, I didn't look behind me.
Doki, how many doors are there?
How many doors?
One, two, three, four, five, six.
See, I can count too.
She took her meds, everybody.
Yeah, I took my meds, you see?
Ah!
God!
Up we go!
I can't go up a floor without you, man!
What?
What the fuck are you doing?
Okay.
Don't go back to zero.
Wait, does it go back to zero if we lose?
Yeah, it goes back to zero.
We lose.
I don't even know how many floors it's supposed to be.
Okay, we're at four!
We're doing it.
Alright.
Everything looks fine.
Okay, there's two fire...
Wait, wait.
The fire hydrants.
There's always been two.
Yeah, but then look at the labels.
Weren't they, like, together?
Like, the same label?
Oh, I don't know.
But also, wait, we started on the other side.
Is that normal?
No, we went here.
We came to this elevator because there was no anomaly.
So we started on that side.
Okay, okay, okay, you're right, you're right.
the meds how many doors if i said fire hydrants then you
agreed with me what's oh fire extinguish
i'm in the oh there's there's there's there's there's
there's there's there's oh the water it's leaking oh my god
what's going on here what why is it that's water and why is
there blood why is there blood also yeah yeah and it's old
blood too because it's dark red.
Ooh, somebody like stubbed her toe or something.
I think that's a pretty extreme stubbed toe.
I think...
So we go in this one, right?
No, we go in the other...
Don't we go in the other one?
There's an anomaly?
Okay, there's three rules again.
I don't remember how we did this.
Oh my god, the V-Tuber is up here now.
And you find the elevator anomaly, press the button from the
elevator you come from.
Yeah, from the elevator you come from.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See?
We're doing it.
I told you this is a team of we.
I told you.
We.
All right.
Nice.
Fifth floor.
Chat, how many floors is this?
They don't know.
They probably don't know.
They've seen gameplay of this before.
Okay.
Let's see.
All right.
Fire extinguisher.
That looks fine.
Everything looks fine.
The medicine looks the same.
Oh!
Did you see that?
What was that?
Come on, get out of here.
Yeah, I think this floor was, I think this floor was cursed.
I think this floor is cursed.
What did you see?
Did you see the skeleton?
Like...
The face?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, I looked at the painting.
I looked at this painting.
There was a face in the painting and I looked at it.
And I was like, oh, what's this?
It showed up on my whole screen.
You're just, I told you, this is a we team.
What I do, you get affected.
Why is this guy just sitting here the whole time?
Why is he here?
He's like triplet.
He's moral support.
Well, he needs to be a team player, I'm telling you.
He's the one that popped out like five minutes later, so we
don't talk about him.
he was in he was in there a little too long yeah he goes
extra cooked in the oven it's fine he's just the silent
archetype you know oh we're like the hewing dewey and louis
i think we're more like the three stooges i think it's good
i think so too so we should be at the other side then be on
this side.
Because if there's no anomaly, we go to the other side.
It is.
How are you still wondering about the rules?
I can't remember this.
We're on the sixth floor.
I'm just finding anomalies, okay?
Wait, no.
Oh yeah, if you find it, go back to the elevator.
Oh my god, I can't do this.
It's really too rough.
It's too complicated.
What do you mean?
It's too rough.
That'd be complicated with these two rules!
I thought you have, what happened to photographic memory?
I didn't say I had photographic memory.
I didn't say that even once.
Wait, what did you say you had photographic something?
I don't remember.
Well, we know you definitely don't have photographic memory.
No, definitely not.
Uh, I don't see any anomaly.
I don't see anything either.
Let's see.
One, two, three, four, five.
Count the doors!
I counted.
There's six.
Okay.
And then the fire extinguisher are real.
They look... they look good.
Oh, wait!
There's a six on this door!
Wait, was there a...
Wasn't there a six?
Was there always a six?
Was it a six?
Six, six?
There's a six on every door.
Was that always the case?
I mean, I think so.
I can't remember.
Wait.
Chat, do your part.
Do your part, chat.
This is a four-player game.
You're a player three and four.
Why are they all labeled six?
What's the point of streaming if you don't help out?
No help.
What are you talking about?
Chat, is this real?
I think it's in an online game.
Guys, has this always been here?
Chat.
Guys, is there anything on the floor?
No help.
Why do they keep saying that?
Guys, you guys Our fucking live tag is literally called bird
cedars As in back cedars Where are my goddamn back cedars?
Okay, back cedars Is there time to ride?
Yes, your time is shine!
You guys love telling the streamer what to do Guys It's an
anomaly What to do?
They said it's an anomaly Wait, which one did we come from?
Which elevator?
No elf?
Wait, you're right.
Oh no, this one.
This one, the orange.
Whatever has the orange Where is the Elp?
What do you mean, whatever has the orange?
Whatever has the orange is where we came from.
What orange are you talking about?
This, the orange, look up.
Oh, like the orange lighting.
Oh my god, you just say the orange.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Literally, because it's orange.
What do you want me to say?
I said orange, look up.
The orange lighting!
Oh, I'm sorry.
Maybe you were in the womb too long.
Hey, I'm not like him.
And he's a good guy, okay?
How would you know?
He doesn't even talk to us.
How do you know that?
So we come here.
I think it's an anomaly.
I don't remember seeing the sixes before.
I'm pretty sure the sixes have always been here.
Right?
Chat.
Chat, if you don't help us, we're going back to floor zero.
Do you want that?
Do you want to...
Do you want to see us back to floor zero?
The orange.
What does no elf mean?
They said yes.
It means no help!
What do you mean?
I don't know.
I'm just thinking maybe there's something in it that says no
help.
They're just being stupid!
super doubt they'll definitely won't help they like it they
like it a little bit okay we're taking the risk we're taking
the risk okay all right oh wait we could have gotten to the
previous floor and oh you're right we could have gotten to
the all right here we go oh oh wait i'm looking though yeah
it was an anomaly i dare you to go in i dare you to go in
wait if you but wait there was It wasn't normal.
It was the six on the doors, the one that I caught.
Oh!
Yeah, all me.
No, I already dared you first.
I dared you.
Come on, go.
I double dared you.
Go, go, go.
By the rules, I double dared.
No, I triple dodged dare you.
I triple dodged dare you.
I go triple dodged dare you.
I caught jinx.
All right, goodbye.
Goodbye, man.
Wait, I get affected.
Okay, this is a team game.
This is a team game.
Don't ever triple, quadruple dog dare me to do anything ever
again.
You mean I can't move on from her death?
I'm not.
Okay.
That's not fair, Debs.
Debs, that is not fair.
She can hold us hostage.
That is not.
I hate all F4s.
out of the game that's what he does okay um do you want to
host it all right we know see if you host it like continue
game and see if we go back to the eighth floor continue does
it do it oh wait wait i just pressed continue i didn't press
host oh i'm on floor eight yeah i told you come here come
here wait okay i think i okay i need okay let me let me see
how i can come on i'm figuring out okay i can watch your
game wait you didn't click host uh you're in a single player
game you have to go back to main menu i just press continue
yeah oh wait oh i see you i see you hold on hold on let me
okay okay i'm in i'm in we're at level eight yeah okay no
yeah no no we're not doing that
You know, you got achievement where, like, I think the game
crashed.
I think that was the achievement.
Yeah, yeah.
Nice.
All right.
Oh, yeah, there was no sixes.
Little friend.
Our brother.
Our triplet.
Our Louis.
Louis was the silent one, right?
I have no idea.
I don't know.
I don't remember.
Aren't those the ducks?
Yeah, they're the...
Yes, it's the duck.
But none of them were silent, right?
Yeah, no, one of them was like the newer DuckTales, the
newest DuckTales.
One of them was like, they made one of them silent.
And then one of them was the Sonic's voice actor.
Oh, yeah, I knew that.
The other one was Abed.
Abed, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I think we're good here.
I think so, too.
I think there's no anomalies.
I don't think so, either.
Yeah.
Move.
God.
No, you move.
What's he?
You move.
Ressal tuber in 20, 25.
You have it in hospital.
Six, six, six.
Ressal tuber.
The sequel to Ressal tuber, we're going to a hospital.
Real.
Real, okay.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
All right.
Ten floor.
Ten.
Ten?
Yeah!
Ten.
Yeah.
good at this game we're really good at this game yeah we can
see all the anomalies i thought the doors would open at some
point i think that's like you know how there's a locked part
i know the doors you can open them but i think you know like
when you start a game it's like easy normal and locked oh
yeah yeah yeah portion you can open the doors oh okay okay
our vision is terrible we have to get we gotta get all the
way close what are these no i can see it i think it's right
right wait why is it like if i'm like halfway in between it
gets like really blurry you i think you need glasses i can
see it fine are you on low quality probably the game the
game defaults to low graphics yeah because it's making me
lag anyway sometimes oh wait really yeah i opened it up this
time and dx maybe it'll help stop it stupid stuck on wombo
combo on your ass she's the violent She's the one that mom
had to take to the hospital.
I have anger issues.
Wait, so do we go in this one?
Yeah, we go to this one because there's no anomalies.
All right.
Up.
Up we go.
Eleven, eleven.
Eleven.
Yeah, it's my soldier jeans, exactly.
She has the killing gene in here.
Oh!
Okay, yeah, yeah, I think that was a nominee.
I think, I don't know about, I think you should have talked
to her.
I can fix it.
I can fix her.
Okay.
All right.
One clock.
One brother.
Oh, okay.
Oh, oh, oh, hey!
Don't turn it on me!
I think, I think something's happening on that floor.
No.
All right, we're five.
See, everything is five.
I'm not letting you out of here.
Oh, look up.
Oh, oh.
We are speed running this game.
I think, I think this is a fire hazard floor with all those
fire alarms.
They're a little paranoid, that's okay.
Yeah.
Hmm.
All right.
All right, this looks normal.
This looks like a normal time.
Yeah.
everything looks good okay so far coffee gold so good our
brother is still here wait there's still have there always
been this many fire alarms i haven't been looking up gamers
don't look up you guys yeah gamers don't look i think it's
wait has there i don't know now i'm paranoid yeah me too
after seeing like 200 fire alarms on one one ceiling now i
don't know has there always been That's a little bit too
much, isn't it?
Right.
I feel like a hospital shouldn't have that many.
They wouldn't do two anomalies with this many, like with a
bunch of fireballs, right?
I mean, the fucking dev crashed our game, so I feel like
that's something.
Wait a minute, this door is huge!
Oh, you're right!
The doors are huge!
Oh, we're tiny!
I like how we pass like five doors.
Every single, we went to the very end of the hall.
we went through five doors and we're like that seems normal
we're regressing in our height in our old age but we were
focused on the fire alarms we're focused on the safety oh oh
wait the door is open i triple dare dog dare you to go
through that door i did it last time you you go you go how
about we do it together no you baby a baby Why did you come
with me last time then?
I did!
No you didn't?
I saw you in the elevator!
I was about to get out of that elevator when you went in.
I was gonna...
Go, go, Doki.
Go, Doki.
Go, go, go in there.
Oh!
Go to the other one.
What do you mean?
There's more than one?
Yeah, another door opened.
What do you mean?
Okay, I just did that door.
It's your turn.
No, no, no, no.
We swap!
Go, Doki!
Whatever jump scare comes out, you get it too!
Okay, good.
There's another one.
Is this some Scooby-Doo shit?
Oh, go get the other one.
Go, go, Ducky!
Go, Ducky!
Go, go, go!
No, go, go, go!
We do the last one together!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, come on, come on, come on.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, there.
I knew it's the same door.
This door opened before.
It is Scooby-Doo.
It's looping.
I told you.
It's Scooby-Doo.
What's new Scooby-Doo?
Someone's like, this instigator mint.
Oh, yeah, it is.
I read that wrong.
Yeah, it is coward dokey instigator mint.
You're ready to, like, rip that chatter apart.
I was like, what do you mean, coward, Vint?
All right.
Can we finally have a regular floor?
We've had like anomalies like back to back.
Um, it's not normal.
It's not normal.
He's happy.
Solidus?
He's like gamer subs.
Well, gamer subs, we- Oh, he's laughing!
Oh my god, he's laughing.
Wait, he is.
Is this a dev?
Ew...
Is this the devs laugh?
Ew.
Oh my god, are you getting louder?
Maybe that's why he's single.
Can we win?
What's going on?
Oh, what the hell?
Wait, was that the bloody butt baby?
It was the SCP!
Yes, it's- Oh my god.
What was that?
What is that?
What's going on?
It's the SCP!
What are you doing?
No, no!
No!
Why is he chasing me?
We...
Oh no!
We gotta get to the elevator!
Why me?
It's like, why is there a MCB?
Why are you relying on me?
Oh my god, it's really coming after you.
Wait, I can't get past!
He's blocking the way!
I took too long!
Oh no!
I'm trying to figure this out!
I'm stuck!
I can't get past!
What if he turns around?
I'm gonna...
Oh, he is not turning around.
He's not turning around.
Wait, I'm not getting...
You need to be in the elevator!
Oh, we escaped from the statue.
We escaped from floor 66.
Oh, we're at a hundred!
We're at a hundred!
Wait, how do we get to a hundred?
I don't know.
We're just speeding running.
Oh, wait, that's the door again.
It's the door again.
Is that...
No!
I think...
I don't think...
I think this is a...
because we we've advanced now it's like a new oh that's why
oh so there's more to this yeah now we have to memorize this
floor okay there's aspirin our brother moved our brother
moved he finally you know like the american healthcare
system where you have to like wait in the waiting room for
like hours hours and hours yeah he's next he just has to
wait another five hours he just needs At least he gets a
chair now.
Everything out here looks the same, I think.
I think besides him.
I think it's the default.
Like, oh, this is what it looks like with no anomalies.
I think.
It has to be.
Because, like, we start off on this floor.
Okay, let's look in here.
Okay, there's a big old couch.
There's two chairs.
Next to the couch.
Memorize that with your non-photographic memory.
Yeah, I'm going to.
Plant, wheelchair.
Two chairs here.
There's two chairs here.
chairs everywhere two hospital beds there's a chair here
vitamins um more vitamins one two three four five hospital
beds and then it's like blue and then purple purple yeah
purple blue all right we should be good we're not gonna
remember this we're not gonna remember this this is why
chat's here chat this is do your part do your part everybody
do your part dude you love hell divers too now it's time to
it's just like hell divers Why is everybody saying no elf?
Why don't you...
Are your H keys broken?
What's going on?
101!
Let's go!
Okay.
Is our brother in the hospital room?
I'm gonna go check on him.
Wait.
Go check on him.
I think everything looks the same out here.
Let's see.
The paintings are the same.
The calendar is a...
Oh!
This room is...
is haunted this room is haunted why go check go look you
baby go go look this room is haunted no no it's not yes it
is how is it what
is he doing here you are such a baby for a sheet ghost you
didn't even know it's like i didn't know i didn't expect
your I didn't expect your cousin to come to this class It's
actually my face reveal Thank you very much You have like a
fucking ghost sheet underneath That's underneath my skin
suit So underneath my skin suit is a tomato Underneath her
skin suit is a Halloween costume At least I don't rot I
don't know that.
I could be like an alien tomato.
You're not ripe anymore.
What about the boomer code?
It's like boomer.
Get it?
Because I say boo a lot.
Where's the myr for her?
Where's the myr for?
Myr.
Wait, did I just see something in there?
What do you mean?
Oh, we showing me a baby now.
Oh, no, there's definitely something in there.
It's twitching.
Oh, yeah.
Go, go, go.
Wait, why?
I went in last time!
No, you didn't!
I don't hear talking about it.
Yes, I did.
Chat would agree with me.
What is that?
We're going together.
As twins, we go in together.
Okay, you go first.
We can't go.
Okay.
You go first.
I'll go after.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Oh, it's a body bag.
Oh, it's, it's like crunchy.
It is?
Yeah.
Oh, why is it crunchy?
Why is it crunchy?
Yeah.
cereal in there?
Bro, are we playing the Mortary Assistant again?
Oh, God, please don't!
I'd rather die again than play the game.
Wait, so how many floors did we get to before we got to the
66?
I don't remember, honestly.
I don't remember.
We were... We definitely didn't do 100 floors, I think.
Yeah.
Oh!
Wait, what?
Did you hear that?
Whoa!
Wait, the another door open.
Oh, okay.
It's time to go.
Get out of here.
If there's no one on the wheelchair, it's either a miracle
or something happens.
So, what do you mean a miracle?
Wouldn't it be more of a miracle if they get out of the
wheelchair?
Not if the wheelchair comes with it.
Yeah, but that means somebody just suddenly learned how to
walk and then they pushed their wheelchair away.
They'd be like, I can walk now.
Yay!
I don't need it.
I don't need this.
He just throws it across the room.
Okay, I think we're safe in this room that way.
Was he always staring at us or?
Yeah, he was always staring at us.
That's our brother.
No, no, no.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, wait, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Okay, what is so?
He's getting sentience, don't he?
He's getting sentience.
He's just being wacky.
He's quirky.
He is.
Oh, oh, Dewey.
Dewey?
I thought it was Huey.
I remember it.
They all like, the names all blur together.
They truly do.
Stop punching me, I swear.
I swear.
You were being too slow.
I'll give you a head start.
I can't punch you anymore, I think.
You've reached your punch limit.
My punch quota.
Yeah.
The punch quota of the day.
Oh!
Another one?
Anomaly.
with all these anomalies we're speed running we're speed
running oh my god oh my god put us on speedrun.com yeah yeah
yeah we're at one hour we're so fine oh you got your punch i
got my punch every floor you're getting you quoted is this a
normal room did we get a normal room this time
Don't look at any weird faces in the pictures.
There's no weird faces in the pictures.
If I look at a weird face, you look at a weird face.
No.
I think this is a normal room.
I think so, too?
I think we got a normal room for one.
I guess the shadows on this.
So weird.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
My shadow is like going over there.
Has this always been like zero, zero, zero, zero, 100?
It has.
Okay, you could barely remember like...
Nice, look at it earlier!
Alright, aspirin.
Yeah, I think this is normal.
I think this is normal.
Oh my god.
Nobody's fucked up if it goes back to zero.
No, there has to be like a...
There's no way.
There's like a checkpoint.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, 100 must be like our checkpoint.
I think we did.
Right?
I'm scared.
We must have done it.
Okay.
Oh, okay, nice.
107.
Oh my god.
Nice.
We finally got to see the other side.
I know, right?
After so long, we've been like...
We've been stuck in there for the longest time.
Oh, Anomaly.
Anomaly.
What?
What did you see?
What was it?
She stopped me, Doki!
What?
He got up, he moved, he didn't need the wheelchair anymore.
There was no one there.
He ran, he was running, he was running.
I think you didn't take your meds.
He ran, Abby!
Oh, that was Doki!
Oh, wait, I mean, it wasn't.
Oh, wait, what?
I saw what happened.
You saw that.
I'm like, I'm just seeing Okay, but there was an anomaly It
was the wheelchair The wheelchair was shaking But then I
thought He got up and ran at me But it was he
I think we were in the hospital for a year He saw me It was
like He's chasing me oh wait there's bodies in here there's
bodies oh there's bodies ah you bitch you bitch don't you
want to see the body i already saw let me rest let me rest
one oh nine give it up for one oh nine someone in the chat
was like i know Doki can be something, but calling her an
anomaly.
SCP tomato.
Oh, my God.
Everything seems fine this time.
Sure.
Yeah.
You're not going to check the room.
You went in there, didn't you?
You don't want to do the room anymore.
I don't want to do the room anymore.
I don't want to.
You used to love the room.
I never loved the room.
You used to love going to the room.
Wait.
Oh.
What?
Oh, okay.
The wheelchair is here.
It was here and it was like shaking.
So that's why I thought.
Oh, so that was the anomaly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was the wheelchair.
It was, but good thing.
Good thing there was an actual anomaly.
All right.
I don't think there is any.
I don't think so either.
I think so.
we're good yeah yeah which would suck because we're about to
hit a mile still i think yeah we're about to hit number 110
110 baby 110 let's go let's go yeah this the light always
like this oh no that's the orange light the orange guys
dokey come on it's the orange light you can't even keep your
own story straight you thought the person running after you
was me I don't know.
I don't know what to expect.
May, June, July.
We care about your health.
Wait, everything looks normal.
I think so, too.
I don't see anomalies.
Anomalies.
Coffee.
Water.
The vending machine looks the same.
Paintings look the same.
I think we're good, too.
Oh!
Look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look, look.
come in here look up oh run run run oh okay okay we're
running we're running we're running we undershirt the rules
we're running all right up we go I like how we have a retry
we're like we don't know but like let's just let's just
re-roll like gotcha we re-roll the anomaly okay Fire
extinguisher seems normal.
Exit seems normal.
Yeah, paintings seem normal.
Paintings.
Uh, the meds are all there because someone's still not
taking their meds.
It's not me.
I don't know.
Wait, is something...
Is something different in here or am I crazy?
Let me check.
I mean, we all know you're crazy, but like...
But am I like crazy?
But are you like, uh, manhara, manhara.
I'm like, are you the good Manhara?
The bad Manhara.
What is the good Manhara?
The ones that are like, she might be crazy, but I think I
can fix her.
And then the bad one was like, there's no fixing her.
I'm just here for the wild ride.
I think we're good here.
I think so, too.
The coffee all look the same.
There's one clock.
There's all the coffee.
coffee stuff.
The calendars look the same.
Yeah, I think we're fine.
Doki makes me Manhara, you guys.
What do you mean?
I literally taught you how to use your own steam.
If anybody's going Manhara.
Okay.
Yay, it's one, one, two.
One, one, two, baby.
we are going to 66 no way i think there's no way why are we
a hundred we have already at a hundred yeah um maybe it'll
go from 112 to like 500 or something yeah we just you can't
the dev did not program there's no way there's no way
there's enough anomalies to make 666 floors there's no way
there's no way and it'll be like next patch update we added
more floors it's just like the spooky the DLC floors let's
see I don't think I see anything the ceiling looks normal
the meds are still there no one's taking them wait wait the
water cooler oh look at that my chat's helping now what
water cooler the water cooler what about it is it this water
cooler which water cooler oh the room Oh no I even walked up
to the other ones Oh my god Six six six Six six just like
the doors See look at that my chat is doing Thanks chat
Thanks that dragon Wait a second My chat said it too They
said in the room Yeah but my chat said the water cooler My
chat probably said it too And I'm just not looking You're
not reading your chat?
Yeah, I'm neglecting them a little bit right now.
Sorry, chat.
It's okay.
All right.
They're not so needy, not like Dragoons.
Whoa!
Whips are, you know, they're chill.
The whips are just as needy as Dragoons.
Stop saying she hates us!
Stop!
Oh my god!
You're supposed to be chill!
She's supposed to be chill!
okay no okay we care about your health the medical center i
think this is a i think this is a fire exit exit water fire
seems to be an okay room guys i think so yeah besides you
whoa what's that supposed to mean we're here for you you
haven't taken your meds since floor one we're here for the
both of us maybe all the triplets are fucked up all right
one one four one one four we haven't failed even once this
is crazy yeah yeah just like for vod watchers skip the first
30 skip the first 30 minutes but we haven't failed one hey
june july I feel like the calendar would have anomalies
soon.
Because I feel like the words are going to change on the
calendar.
There's an anomaly.
It's an anomaly?
It's the anomaly.
Go check.
See if you can find it.
Come on.
I found it.
You find it.
Exit.
Oh, there's the devs!
Is that the dev?
Yeah, I think it is.
It's the dev on this PC.
Oh, you're right!
Oh, my God!
He's watching his play!
He's actually watching.
He's actually moving!
Oh, my God!
Ew, he's smiling.
He's watching us.
Oh my god, is this like what it feels to like when we see
our chat watch us at the panels?
This is what I see when I, like, end the stream.
No, now it's just sad.
1-1-5.
We're here.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Yeah, where's your other SCPs?
Checking the calendar.
Seems normal.
May, June, July.
We care about your health.
Min, we care about you.
You guys, please, take your med.
Ah!
Tor, look, he cares about your health, Min.
He cares about your health.
Yeah.
The shadow man is here.
Okay.
This is a really tall hospital.
I'm not going to lie.
I know.
How many sick people are there?
I think they have other things to worry about if they need
to make a hospital this big.
May do that.
It's like the only hospital in the country.
They abolished all the hospital and just kept this one.
I think...
I think we're five.
We haven't even been in here.
He's like, no, I think we're fine.
I think we're fine.
Has there always been this many plugs, outlets in the
hospital?
I don't know.
I wasn't looking.
Oh, no.
You've been to a hospital before.
I have.
Oh, my God.
I thought that was you.
Your curly hair.
Wait, he's too big.
I was going to say, he looks different.
He looks huge.
Oh, my God.
He drank a lot of milk.
Brother.
Brother, we're all supposed to be the same size.
No, wait.
I think we're just small.
We're small.
wait are we getting smaller are we getting smaller we're not
gonna be able to reach them we're not gonna be able to reach
oh my god they also shrunk yeah oh my god we like cool back
up oh no oh it's sdp oh please god no oh sdp is this where
are you i'm in a i saw a maze for a second oh yeah me too oh
no Wait, where are you?
What is that?
Oh, there you are!
There's things coming out!
Oh, oh!
Come on, come on.
Wait, come on, go, go, go.
Wait, what's the maze rule?
What's the maze rule?
Ah...
That's not it!
Ah!
I'm reaching out to you!
I終!
That's it!
I'm dead!
Blood!
You're dead!
I'm dead!
He blinked, he touched me!
He touched me!
You just have to avoid him!
Come on, okay!
Oh my god.
Oh, God, there's a ton of them.
Oh!
There's a ton of them!
Man, it is!
Run around, run around, run around!
Run around, face through them!
You're a ghost!
You're a- oh, they stopped.
Hey there.
I gamed.
I'm a gamer.
Okay, so I saw the dead end and I ran back to the dead end.
Why did you- why did you do that?
Why did you do that?
Why did you- You might as well just say goodbye to me.
We have a new room!
Wait, maybe?
Oh, it's- 200 we're at 200 yeah we have a new room we have a
new room yeah yeah yeah we know no it's the other door the
other door door wait so this is all the normal this is the
normal yeah this is the normal and we gotta figure out the
oh my god oh here's our brother he's finally got into the
he's not even on the exam table he has a bullet in his neck
he has a tumor in his neck oh my god what happened oh my god
brother brother brother brother no brother brother no
brother this is how we find out oh my god brother is that a
bullet or a tumor i can't tell what is kind of looks like a
bullet right i think he got shot in the neck that's why he
can't speak they got his throat no brother you have to talk
to us brother brother we're worried about You just, you'll
wait 10 more hours and the doctors will be here to help with
the surgery.
It's just a bullet.
Don't worry about it, man.
Don't mind the fact that we're in a, don't mind the fact
that this is where all the dead bodies go, brother.
And it's possible to save you.
Yeah, why is the morgue in the same place?
That's the x-rays?
Yeah.
What's happening?
Oh, it is Mortary Assistant.
We're back, baby.
Oh, no.
We're back.
So these, there's three open.
Okay, one, no, there's four.
Three wide open.
This one.
Oh, I'm sorry for the details.
I wanted to provide the details.
I mean, if we're like looking at, okay, then it's not four.
It's five, six open.
It's six open if you wanted the details.
There we go.
Yeah, that's what we want.
We're here to spot the anomaly.
I really like that they kind of try to spruce up this room
with some plants.
Oh, yeah, some plants to be like, you know, you might be
dying, but at least there's like something to look at.
And the smiling, the smiley face right here.
Everything's okay.
You're not gonna die.
We have the, what is this?
Oh, no, it's French.
Sue, us, electricity.
Wow.
You like my French?
Oh, sorry, I'm sorry.
You don't know, you don't know that.
You don't even speak French.
Uh, yeah.
Parle-parle-parle-vous-francé.
Ah, yeah.
I'm a bell doki.
Move.
That's how you say doki in French, by the way.
Doki.
It's like, My name is Toby Fox.
Let's say that.
All right, let's see.
Oh, this is apparently CPR because they're kissing.
Wow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they're kissing.
We're gonna do that to our brother.
Preparation and execution.
We're gonna, we're gonna kiss the bullet away.
We're gonna suck it out of his throat.
You'd be like...
That's what brothers do.
They suck the bullets out of their...
Yeah.
Get yourself a true brother.
Now suck the bullet out of your neck.
If you don't kiss your brother, for him to leave, you're not
a real brother.
It's true.
Wait, was that always there?
The yellow sign thing?
Oh, I don't know, actually.
I think so.
Was that always there?
You sure?
Um, there's an anomaly.
Oh shit.
Why are you running backwards?
Oh, my bad.
Why did you run forward?
Okay, at least I didn't die.
Like someone.
You didn't even see the body bag.
I literally said there's an anomaly.
I literally said, oh, there's an anomaly.
There's an anomaly, and then...
I saw it first!
Yeah, but you stayed there!
No, I literally...
You pushed me back into the room!
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't think I pushed anybody back.
That is, he say, she say...
He say, she say...
Sally sells seashells at the shore.
I can't even say that.
You can't even say it!
Why, what is it then?
What is it?
Sally sells seashells by the seashore!
She says She says Sally says sea shores by the sea
I'm sorry I was an ESL class As English is my first language
English is your first language Yeah I was put in ESL When I
was younger Yeah you needed it You needed it clearly I think
this floor is good Yeah I think so too I don't think there's
any anomalies I don't think so.
Two, oh, three!
Yeah!
That took a lot longer.
It was like actually like deciding if we were right.
Yeah, like should we give her that one?
They didn't want to, yeah, they don't want to give us the
point.
Come on, game.
They're like, I don't think they actually figured it out.
I think I heard something, but.
Inside the room?
I don't know.
It sounds like flickering lights or something.
something.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
This calendar has been the same thing over and over again.
Over and over again.
When is there like something new on the calendar?
Brother.
Brother, why is there still a bullet in your neck?
Please talk to us, brother.
That's all we want from you.
We just want you to talk to us.
We miss you, brother.
We miss your singing, brother.
I think everything on this floor is fine.
The coffee is fine.
The clock still says 6.
30.
6.
There's no 6s on the doors.
I was like, why is my chat doing smiley?
Is this because of the damn smiley in this room?
Yeah, the board.
All right, up we go.
204!
4, 4, 4, 4, 4, 2, oh, 4!
Yeah!
Isn't it like we see?
the elevator, like, dropped down the zone.
I know.
I would, like, literally cry.
We went through the maze.
Oh, anomaly.
What's the anomaly?
You have to go see it.
Come on, let's go inside.
No, we got to see it.
I saw it.
You go see it.
Oh, no.
He's sad.
No!
He's sad now.
He's the bullet.
He realized it's terminal.
Oh, well.
We can have another brother.
Oh, my God.
Ow.
What's going on with you?
Go.
I'm letting my issues out because my brother's dying.
Come on.
Come on, Doki.
We got to leave the elevator.
We got to go find the anomaly.
Come on.
Yeah, the elevator.
Yeah, that's right.
Can't hit me back into the elevator now.
I'm in the corner.
Yeah, yeah.
All right.
Let's see.
Oh, he's happy again.
Yippee.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck is that?
Go in.
I saw.
I go in.
Oh.
Where's the anomaly?
I see him.
Closer to him.
You get closer.
You found it.
You should get closer.
That's not the rule because last time you didn't do that
either.
What are you talking about?
We did it together.
We're a team.
That's all we have now.
Our brother's dying.
What are you doing?
Come on.
Get over there.
I don't think I can smack you anymore.
You reached your quota.
I want to get closer.
It's just a man with a brain.
It's the opposite of us.
Is he like clipping through?
Oh, we don't know.
You see, class, that's where our brain is.
I can't, I actually can't tell if it's like a headless guy.
No, he's like clipped through.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
He was like clipped through.
All right, come on, let's get closer.
Let's get closer.
Come on.
What do you mean he wants to say hi?
I think he's just chilling in there.
He's just smiling.
Wait, I don't think even...
Is that a brain?
Or is he wearing like a handkerchief on his head?
Oh.
Yeah.
It's a handkerchief.
It's a handkerchief on his head.
Yeah.
I was like, wait a minute.
That looks like cloth.
He didn't come after us.
It's fine.
Yeah.
He was just sitting high.
He looks really like sinister, though.
Yeah.
He was just like, hey.
That's what he does on his free time.
What?
All right.
Hide in.
It's your turn to go to that room.
gonna look at the other anomalies oh i found the anomaly oh
okay you go in there come on come on come on come on what do
you mean what am i what am i what am i come on get the
anomaly come on what the fuck is that wait that's just a kid
it's just a kid it's just a kid it's just literally just a
kid they get like like kid png on google no it's a kid it's
like just a kid what's he doing like the children's
hospital.
They put it in to make it seem more friendly.
They put a child in the lights.
It's like a skibbity.
A skibbity.
Oh no.
I thought you were... This is when boomers try to relate to
the young people.
They just say random things.
Skibbity.
You can't just say skibbity all the time, Doki.
Oh my god.
You can't just...
I'm gonna die!
Go in there, I dare you No, what do you mean, I dare you?
Oh, I double dog dare you, I triple dog, dare you Come on,
go in there, go in there, go in there I quadruple dog, dare
you, come on, go in there Go in there, go in there I
quadruple dog Oh, you met your punch quota, don't make me
punch you I know you met your punch quota Oh, you got lucky,
you got lucky I guess I can go in there, I mean if you
insist If you Oh, isn't it working?
Fuck it.
Oh, my God.
It's like a triple date dog dare you to jump over that cliff
right now.
You were too baby.
You couldn't even go in.
Oh, yeah.
As the blades are rolling down.
Oh, my God.
You're too baby.
I went in.
The door shut.
It was like so crazy.
Well, it wasn't you went in.
I punched you in.
true but these rooms always have the anomalies they're kind
of crazy yeah i think it's because like i think like the
devs ran out of ideas for the main area so they're just put
it all in maybe we've exhausted all of them like we've seen
all of them they're like they're like please leave the
hospital we're done here i don't think there was an anomaly
did anyone see anything water i'm triple checking i'm gonna
go look at this sign the caution sign i'm gonna look at the
It's done.
Wet floor.
Water.
This floor is always wet.
Where's the fucking janitor?
What do you mean this floor is always wet?
There's a wet sign.
It's been here since the beginning.
Why is every floor wet?
Wait, no we're not.
What do you mean?
Has this page always been, like, peeled off?
What page?
This one.
Has this page always been peeled off?
I think so.
I don't think they would do something that subtle.
know it's this six six six you will never get six never get
six six six is that what it says yeah you will never get six
six oh i want to prove you wrong yeah we told you this was a
24 hour stream oh my god it's actually gonna go to us I told
you!
This floor is 666.
You know, I honestly thought this was going to be, like, a
short game.
I thought so, too.
I thought it was going to be, like, 20 floors.
Just, like, the exit 8.
But we're actually going to 666.
But we, like, jump a lot.
What?
That's true.
You found it?
Isn't the plans?
Were you big punching me back in?
We're both looking at the anomalies together.
Yeah, I'm finding them.
I'm finding them.
I found all of them.
I found every single one so far you haven't even come on
this is a wee game dokey you have to help you said you were
like oh i told you i told you okay okay you think there's no
anomaly i don't know i think there's what i think there's no
anomaly oh did you find an anomaly no i think there's no
anomaly
I'm going back.
I'm going to back to cover your tracks.
Mint, is there an anomaly in this room?
Yes!
What is it?
Can you tell me what the anomaly is?
The X-ray!
Yay!
Can you say X-ray?
X-ray!
The X-ray.
X-ray.
What?
Say that again?
Can you say the X-ray?
The X-ray?
The X-ray.
Up we go.
Oh my god.
You're like Boots and I'm Dora.
Okay.
I think all the anomalies are just in that room.
We didn't even say anything.
We just turned her.
Hey, at least I run out of the elevator.
You just walk out.
You crawl out like a baby.
You're like, you're waiting.
You're, no, no, no.
You're waiting for me.
Waiting for me to run into anything.
I was nowhere.
No, no, no, uh.
Uh-uh.
Are we typing a comment to this room with me?
Who's the baby now?
I thought that was you again.
I thought somebody was running at you again.
I don't think there's an anomaly this time.
We don't know yet.
There really is like nothing in any, in like the outside.
It's kind of crazy.
is now and just in this room yeah that makes it easier it
really does and then before they add like they actually add
one anomaly outside is there anything i really don't see
anything i don't see anything also my chat was like look up
but there's nothing up top oh are we supposed to gamers
don't look up you guys yeah guys if somebody adds up uh
upstairs then they're not real gamer it's true a poser check
behind the standing whiteboard you know what you're right i
was looking there earlier there's still okay there's what
what you mean look up they keep saying look up stop don't i
am not up they said look up i'm looking up there's like
something up top are they are they gaslighting us i think
they're gaslighting you yeah there has to everybody say No,
they're saying gamer subs.
Oh, yeah.
Anyway, check out our gamer subs content keeper.
Use code Boomer.
Boomer.
Oh, wait, there's no, I think we're good.
No, no, everybody keeps saying look up.
I don't know they're fucking with us.
I don't know.
They're not saying that to me.
I think they're fucking with you.
Oh, okay, yeah, you're right.
You're right.
I think so too.
So I guess there's no anomalies.
Right?
Cut.
All right.
Everyone keeps seeing the smile.
Yeah, because...
The smile in the room!
No!
Let's go back and look at the room!
I can't...
What?
They keep saying they're missing.
They're yelling that I'm blind.
What?
They're saying we're blind.
My chat is not saying that.
Are you sure you're not looking at your chat?
I am looking.
I'm looking.
There's nothing here!
What is your chat saying about my chat?
They're saying she's getting gaslight.
Everyone's saying the smile.
What do you mean by the smile?
Where's the smile?
Don't punch me.
Don't take your aggression out on me.
Mint, let's get you to bed.
What are you talking about?
It's Doki!
Dragoon's SMH.
So true, chat.
So true.
goes are you really gonna let the wist say that fight fight
fight and you know like the the meme the simpsons me with
the monkeys fighting and then like oh yeah surrounding him
with money okay we're going to level 12.
it's gonna be level 12.
212 okay 2 12.
yeah oh i was getting gaslighted
don't take it out of me i kept track of you're really gonna
let the whisp do this to you the whips are good we care
about your health we care about your health wait a second oh
never mind what oh i thought something was different but it
doesn't i think everything yeah i think everything looks the
same there's outlets here suit song us electricity
Wait?
We're the same height.
Oh, never mind.
We're the same height as our brother.
Hey, everything looks the same.
Oh!
Wasn't this on the other side?
No, it was always there.
Never mind.
Yeah, the car was always there.
No, I meant this.
Oh, the chair?
No, this, this, whatever this.
No, this was always here.
Never mind.
It was always here.
I was thinking about this thing, like the little camera.
yourself you can't trust nobody not even yourself these
games make you paranoid man you think about and they're like
where's the where's the anomaly i know anomaly but like
everything looks the same yeah i think so i don't think
there's any difference here it looks normal looks normal
yeah this looks normal i guess we go all right here are the
tiles bigger i don't think so
I'm looking up.
I looked up.
We're good.
All right, here we go.
Next floor.
Yay!
2-13!
Wait, people are saying there was an extra light switch.
Uh-oh.
Don't say that.
2-13!
Whips!
What the hell?
Don't whips!
I'm letting you do!
Oh, I found the anomaly.
I found it too.
Yeah, let's go.
Okay, I don't want to go in that cold.
Yeah.
I think our brother's getting to his operation right now.
That's mean it's been five hours.
He went through two different rooms.
I don't even know what light switch they mean.
I think they just made it up.
Oh, these two maybe.
Oh, so there's always been two.
Brother!
Did they take away the bullet?
I think they did.
I think he looks a little happier now.
I'm pretty sure.
Can you see that smile?
It's a QR code, guys.
Wait, what is the QR code?
Is it to, like, this YouTube channel?
I know it.
It's getting darker.
Is it?
Oh, it is.
Yeah.
Guys, scan that QR code.
Scan the QR code.
Where's it going?
Oh, my God, it's fully dark now.
Where does it go, guys?
Scan it.
Scan it, scan it.
I bet you it goes to, uh, it goes to, like, my affiliate
link.
Yeah.
It goes to, it goes to Mince Gamer subs.
My chat was like, hold still we can't scan it because it's a
YouTube link.
It's a YouTube link?
Is it?
Oh, it's a Rick Roll.
No way.
It's a Rick Roll.
Wait, it has.
No way.
Hold on.
Are you going to scan it?
Is it actually a Rick Roll?
No.
It's like a five second.
It's like a five second clip.
It's unlisted.
Oh.
What is it?
I don't know.
It's a black screen.
I can't I can't figure out Put that volume up I'm trying
Hold on Hold on I'm gonna watch it again Oh my god It's
disappearing What did he just say?
Can you?
Can you hear me?
Hold on Yeah I heard it I heard it on your end Okay I'm
What?
I can't hear him Wait wait Wait wait Wait again I'm turning
off my nose Noise gate So Okay Can you hear me?
I'm trapped in the game Oh I'm trapped in the game Oh my
god.
Oh my god.
There's another VTuber in here.
I think we need to leave then.
We need to get out.
How dare they come to iStream.
This is an exclusive collab.
Yeah, this is an exclusive collab.
What are you trying to do coming to iStream?
You thought it was a Rickroll?
People like chat were saying it's a Rickroll.
I know they didn't even bother to scan it.
because I'm brave.
Fuck you.
Alright.
Oh!
Our brother!
Our brother's been possessed!
What do you mean?
Our brother!
Stop punching me!
Oh!
Oh my god!
He's only looking at me.
I think he's obsessed with me.
Whoa.
Brother, no.
It's not Alabama.
It's not Alabama, brother.
That bullet sit thing, sir.
Let's don't say that.
Uh-oh, wait.
Isn't it normally at 16 that we get to the...
When do we get to the...
I think at 16, we do, yeah.
Yeah, so we have to get through this one.
I think...
Everything looks same.
You say that literally two seconds into walking into the
room.
You say everything looks the same.
That's how much I need.
That's all the until I need.
It's one room.
You would have never noticed, brother.
You never would have noticed.
You never would have looked at him.
You never pay attention to brother anymore.
You never pay attention to him.
Oh yeah?
How?
You were the one that was supposed to look after him when he
got shot.
I can't.
I've, you know what?
I think you were the one who shot him.
You're the one who shot him.
You play Apex.
Yes, I don't play Apex.
You knew I was going to a supermarket for mom.
You knew I was going to a supermarket for mom to do, to buy
us groceries.
Wait, I think there's actually no anomalies.
Brother was in your chair.
this happened now we're trapped in the haunted hospital we
only call him brother he doesn't even have a name brother
brother because he can only say brother so we named him we
named him he's like a pokemon yeah he's like go brother go
brother brother brother brother i think there's no anomalies
It's like your Sean situation all over again.
Sean!
Press F to brother.
Uh-oh.
Are we about to go into the SCP world?
SCP time.
Oh, God.
2-17.
Wait, what's up?
Brother.
This is your fault.
No way!
This is your fault!
What?
Wait, can we go back?
Hold on, hold on.
16 floors again!
No, no.
No, no, no, no.
What if it goes back to, like, 100?
We can just go back up again.
What does it go up?
Oh.
Um.
What did you do?
I...
What did you...
What did you do?
Okay.
I...
I don't know.
When an elevator just gives us question marks, I don't think
that's a good sign.
Okay, you go, brother.
Wait.
The elevator doors close on the other side.
what did you do i'm going why is the elevator closed brother
brother brother what did you do brother what did you do
brother what are you not going inside brother i don't see
anything in here is it like patient zero are we back to zero
floor oh someone said we're checking your mistake oh where
did we mess up this is the test floor this is the test floor
where did we mess up the scale the scale was never here
before right I thought it was I even looked at it you can
review the floor no this is a test floor oh wait or like the
floor that we messed up yeah I think this is the floor we
were just at that we messed up oh what did we mess up on
everything looks was the scale was never there what oh no no
i found it i found it oh oh they're sad at our mistakes yo
this is so messed up that's so messed up we have to do all
16.
we have to do six okay no it's a fast speed run because
they're all in the same room it's always in that room that's
true that's true yeah yeah yeah we can do this come on we
can do this come on we can still get into speedrun.com oh we
just happened oh okay we just spammed it 200 okay Oh.
We got it.
200.
Speed run.
My screen went black.
Oh, no.
Wait, can you see anything?
Yeah, I can now.
Okay.
All right.
Is there anything in there?
Do you think it's going to be the same stuff as before?
Okay, I feel like it's just randomized.
Well, that means we know what to look for, right?
Yeah.
We've seen majority of it.
We've seen all 16.
Yeah, we should know what to do.
Yeah, right.
Yeah.
All right.
So, next floor.
Next floor.
Oh, wait.
200 is always the test floor.
Remember that.
Oh, you're right.
So there's nobody.
Nothing here.
There's nothing here.
We're sick.
We're sorry.
We fucked up, so we were pretty tired.
Oh, my God.
Brother, we're sorry.
Brother, brother.
Oh, don't push me in.
It's this.
What floor is it?
It's the saws that come from the ceiling.
Oh, you looked up.
Yeah, I looked up.
I wasn't a gamer.
All right, brother.
We're going to get you out of here, brother.
pressure we're gonna get you out brother is possessed
brother is possessed let's go speed run speed run why is it
16 i can't believe on the last floor we i know right on the
last but that means we have to check the behind the thing
every time unless it's obvious oh uh the guy is in the
locker the handkerchief guy yeah maybe they'll give it give
all of them to us maybe all 16 is just every single anomaly
now.
I mean, it's easy because it's like always in that room too.
Where's the replay ability?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, oh, the x-rays are upside down, all
right i'll be the elevator pressure no you're not gonna be
okay we'll take turns we'll take turns you go next you'll go
next yeah you're faster you no no no no no you go okay okay
now you go and i'll press the button what if i mess up just
go hurry up i run in there oh my god why are you so slow you
know what everything is really make me do this?
Do this?
I'm gonna do it my way.
Check behind the whiteboard!
Check behind the whiteboard.
No, there's nothing out behind the whiteboard.
I don't trust you.
I don't trust...
Oh, yeah, you don't trust me!
Look at that!
You don't even trust me to do your job!
Okay, I think we're good.
Wait.
See?
At least I'm meticulous.
No, we gotta go to the other side, right?
Oh, yeah, we gotta go, yeah.
I was testing you.
I was testing to see if you remember.
all right okay that sucks because now we have to run all the
way to the other side no yeah because what if there's
anomaly two oh seven don't worry i'll be here what if it's
the body bag wait why am i going because then we know if
there's anomaly okay it is a very far run it is a pretty far
run i'm scared of being in here You're peeing in here?
Beeing in here?
Wait, I think we're good, actually.
Oh, no, that's the QR code.
It's the QR code.
Oh, it's the QR code?
The guy who's trapped?
See, look, it would be a waste of time if I ran in there,
too.
Get out of my way.
How did you know?
I said being, you guys.
It's Doki that brought up the pee.
Alright, you go.
You go.
Go.
Run.
Because we're taking turns.
I did not agree to that.
I hope it's the body bag.
If it's the body bag, we have to do this all over again.
No, we don't.
You just run over here.
Get in there.
What if I die?
Go inside.
Oh, it's a sad face.
He's sad.
Okay, sad face.
Yeah, he learned it was terminal.
So we have to, we have to, we have to, get a specialist.
One of us is going to get the body back.
It's going to be really unfortunate.
It's like Russian roulette over the body back.
Okay, I'll go.
Did you get the body back?
I sure hope not.
I know where it's at, though, in the beginning, so, okay.
It's not fair.
Wait, that's not fair.
You know where it's at.
I'm not going to tell you either.
Wait a second.
but make sure it's not the child too um not the child i
don't see anything actually oh okay i think we might be
behind the white boy i did it okay are you sure i don't
think it's anything yeah seems good yeah let's go nice if we
fuck up we know who to blame you could have checked you
literally could have taken the two seconds to go i trust you
i don't doubt you like you did to me Okay, 210.
I trust you.
Your turn.
All right, my turn.
Go in.
Go inside.
I'm going in.
Nope.
There's nothing there.
Behind the whiteboard.
I checked the whiteboard.
Check for the 666.
You will never get out.
I checked the 666.
There's nothing here.
Are you sure?
Oh, oh, you don't trust me again?
There's no baby face.
No baby face.
Oh, oh, you're coming inside.
the room too i mean i'm like right next to it you know wow
you don't even trust me no i don't i don't i gave like full
commitment to all your sources i was like yep you said
there's nothing in there all right i don't even need to
check okay because it's so on gonna be on the far side of
the room i think we should go in the next one together all
right you know what let's yeah i agree with that do that
together yeah you guys this is what friendship is teamwork
this is teamwork all right okay let's go all right let's go
i'm right beside you okay i'm just i'm just let's make a
show okay why are you looking back why are you looking back
if you fully trust me you wouldn't look back oh okay all
right give him his privacy he's getting operated on you guys
it's so rude to go in there naked right now a brother won't
look okay let's go again together together together together
why did you keep looking back i think it's the body bag i
think it's the body bag I think it's the body bag.
I think it's the body bag.
It's not the body bag.
There's no child.
I hope it's nothing so that we can get closer to the room.
Yeah, me too.
I don't think there is anything.
I don't see anything either.
Chat.
Yeah.
I looked up.
Oh.
Thanks for the raid.
I don't know who raided me.
Brother?
Thank you.
backwards.
I think we're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Brother?
Don't worry, brother.
We're gonna make it to the 300 floor.
Thank you so much, friend.
Yay!
Oh, blames.
Thank you.
213.
Now we take turns again.
Oh, it's the child face.
It's the child, okay.
God damn it.
Okay.
Alright, don't keep your turn.
Together, guys.
It's you.
It's all you.
What happens if you get there?
Go on in.
Oh, there's no body bag.
Dang it.
Oh, you don't trust me.
Every time there's no talking body bag, you go right in.
It's the 666.
I think the next one is the body bag.
The next one has to be the body bag because we only have two
legs.
It's okay because if it's the body bag, I can see it from
here.
I'll let you know immediately.
I'll be next to the button.
It's the body bag.
We're
on this side, you know.
Yeah.
Okay.
This one has to be the smiley then, right?
Because we haven't gotten.
Oh, yep.
There it is.
Oh, my God.
That's so cheap.
The last floor with the smiley to make.
He must have done it so that the last floor would always be
like, smiley face right there's nothing oh oh cp time no no
no no oh what's happening what's that i can't see anything i
can't see anything what is that oh what the hell it's like a
zombie it's like the you need these doors zombie but there's
like a guy blocking the door too there's two of them there's
two zombies okay wait we gotta split up this way this way
this way okay i i got those okay the zombies chasing me i'll
sacrifice myself to you What do you mean?
I got started chasing, getting chased by a zombie.
Oh, they're coming after me, they're coming after me,
they're coming after me.
Wow, no!
Oh my God.
They fucking ran into me!
Why can't I- I can't believe it, I can't believe you walking
dead man.
I can't believe you walking dead me.
You, you left that guy kill it.
I literally watched him bum rush you.
Oh, we have a new floor!
We have new door!
We have a new door!
All right, time to see you.
What's all different in this room?
Okay.
Brother, he's a doctor now.
He's a doctor.
No, he's at the, he's finally getting his diagnosis.
Wait, oh gosh, this is going to be so bad.
We have to check behind these curtains.
Oh, no.
There has to be somebody behind these.
There's going to be something on the computer.
There's going to be people behind.
Oh, God.
Okay, so, like, he's waiting for the doctor to tell him what
the surgery was like.
if your surgery was a success or not yeah yeah the operation
time oh my god brother brother we're here for you yeah we're
holding your hand brother we're holding your hand for you
brother washing your hands drying your hands isn't that like
kind of unsanitary the hand dryer the hand dryer next yeah i
think the hand dryer doesn't do as well those have like so
many germs in them it's like that's true yeah he's pregnant
our brother congratulations The bullet was actually a baby.
You're going to be a mother.
The first ever throat burst.
You're like a hairball.
You're like a child.
Ew.
I just noticed this room is like in the middle, so no matter
what we do.
Oh, yeah.
No matter what.
We have to run over there.
301.
I can't believe this is actually 666 but it's really like oh
my god brother scared me It's really like It's like 16
floors each I think it's 15 technically because the first
oh, I see the anomaly wait Yeah, I see what oh, what the
fuck their babies It's his baby It's the throat baby It's
the throat baby Oh my god!
It's triplets!
It's actually how you're ready at the elevator?
We saw the babies.
I'm not ready for this.
It's one for each of us.
I'm not ready to be a mom.
I'm not.
We're uncles now.
We're uncles.
Brother.
I can't believe it.
Congratulations, brother.
It's like how like triplets are like predisposed to like.
Wait, what?
What is that?
You heard that?
Did you hear that?
Yeah.
It's like a...
Yeah, I heard that.
Check behind.
That's one of the...
What do you mean, check...
I'll go right side.
Okay, and also go the left side.
What do you mean also?
I chose my curtain.
It's your turn.
I think I'm going to...
Okay.
I'm...
Come on, go.
Okay.
Check.
Oh, I heard it again.
Oh, I think it is in there.
I think so, too.
Okay, I got an idea.
Watch that jump.
I was going to, like, jump over here and look over the
curtain.
Together.
Okay.
We're all we had.
This is for you, brother.
It keeps, I think it's saying here.
Oh, it's like, okay, I'm curious.
There's nothing here.
Wait, what?
Oh.
It's just going.
Okay, all right, so we're fine.
We're fine.
But that has to be an anomaly, right?
Yeah, that's an anomaly.
Yeah, yeah.
Someone said look up.
Is it up on the...
Okay, they all didn't always say look up.
There's nothing up.
the computer no oh i heard another noise too he went wow i
think it's just the same thing you just you're just
projecting hey dev if you need anybody to make noises for
your uh
thank you for the rain i didn't see it i didn't catch you
thank you all right where do you go thank you so much I
don't think I see anything you looked for two seconds oh
wait was this computer was on I see something oh whoa it's
kind of that's a cool effect actually that's actually a cool
effect whoa look at all these eyes oh they blink yeah
they're pretty neat they gave me goosebumps they were
blinking that's just triggering my trip yeah Trimophobia
warming?
Oh.
Alright.
3-0-4!
Oh, I'm stuck.
Oh my god.
Yeah, go ahead.
Go ahead.
I'll go right side Nothing on the right You never go on the
way Oh wait I have an anomaly What's the anomaly They're
playing It's like that Maze escape game Yeah they're playing
They're playing this game They're gonna show us Wait It's
going to the room That's our room Wait uh oh I don't want to
see that Wait are they out here Are they You think there's
someone out here?
No no they're in our room now Oh They're looking at the
anomalies Oh and it stopped stops okay boo oh they're not as
gamers as us you know yeah yeah they would they they got too
scared and stopped playing the game yeah we're never scared
we made it to 305 we are the first youtubers to make it to
305 are we actually what do you think
don't lie on the internet don't don't don't here i'll go
right okay i'll go there Nope, no anomaly.
Anomaly, there's an anomaly on the computer.
What is it this time?
Oh, hey!
Yeah.
There's like, um, insert your OC.
What are you talking about?
It could be you, like, those, like, drawings where you buy
art and, like, insert your character here.
And the black screen is, like, the character.
What?
Did we see the same thing?
Yeah, I saw it!
There was a black character out loud in there.
This is a way!
I see H, your character here.
I didn't see that at all.
What did you see?
I think you need to take your meds, girl.
No, I think you need it.
My chat saw the same thing.
No, wait, you, you, I'm, okay, I'll go left.
No anomalies here.
I let you go.
Yeah, what the hell is dokey cooking?
I don't know that.
She's overcooking.
Oh, you don't trust me.
You're looking at the left side because you didn't even
trust me.
Okay, well, look at the right side.
double checker answers wait was the needle always this huge
what needle i don't think there's ever been a needle i'll be
honest i haven't been looking oh wait was there always been
like the disease disease history yeah wait maybe we should
pay attention to this table yeah maybe yeah i feel like we
should wait has there always a history history it's history
okay it's always been here okay okay okay it's just his
brother okay This doctor is just illiterate.
I think we're good.
I think we're good too.
Yeah.
History.
See, my chat said it was always there.
Someone said the plant.
What do you mean the plant?
The plant?
No, the plant has always been that green.
3-0-7!
Yeah!
Bing!
Nice.
I hate it when it, like, pauses after a while.
I know, right?
Because it's just like, what do you mean?
It's Bing, right?
Brother?
Oh, my goodness.
right side right side safe right side safe safe left side
left side safe safe history hmm history hmm floor nothing
ceiling nothing exit water plant brother not pregnant
anymore oh he has had the babies he's had the babies it was
it wasn't a bullet all along it was like an egg you are king
what happened to the baby it's like being washed yeah
they're in the baby ward the baby ward yeah the ward for all
you guys the big baby ward all right it's time brother
brother oh um help me Help me, help me.
Help, I'm gonna drown.
I'm gonna die, I'm gonna drown.
I'm gonna- I'm gonna drown, I'm gonna die.
The door is gonna open, don't worry.
It's gonna open, I'm gonna drown, I'm gonna die, I'm gonna
drown, I'm gonna die.
You're doing great, sweetie.
See, I told you.
There we go.
God.
She's such an overreacting.
Those were all my wisps tears, but when I don't start the
stream.
She hates us!
man what an overreaction was saying that she was gonna you
know what i get those those those um anomalies a lot i think
it's because i'm not a big ass baby and i have to go into
the room look at this wait has this always been white the
floor it looks wider than usual yeah it looks like extra
bright oh um you might want to get out of there why what
what did you see no wait what did you see Okay, you have to
go back in until you find the anomaly.
No, no, no, I already found it.
You go in, you go in.
It's the floor.
Oh!
We both had to reset the game if I can crush!
So I think the reason why it was wider was because the
ceiling was closing it.
It was like getting brighter.
The light was getting closer to the floor.
Managed to avoid drowning.
And getting crushed.
Okay, I went in first already, so it's your turn.
Okay, now it's my turn to go in first.
Brother, safe.
Computer, safe.
Right side, safe.
Left side, history.
History.
Lights, not crushing us.
Sync, dajjobu.
Blow dryer, still unhygienic.
filled with germs I think brother give us a thumbs up if
we're safe and before they insert like one anomaly outside I
know right I feel like we should still be checking but they
didn't last time so alright this is it okay alright 311 311
yeah yeah Power hand dryers unhygienic.
Well, if they're in a bathroom...
Oh, you go in first this time.
If they're in a bathroom, they just blow all the germs onto
your hands.
Right side, nothing.
Left side, safe.
History...
PC.
Ground, nothing.
Sailing, still there.
Brother, nothing in his brain.
Nothing going on in there.
Brother, brother's going through.
it wow there's there's no way there's not an anomaly you
cannot know anomalies yeah the poopy air gets blown around
it's disgusting it's like it's like when you're it's like
you have to change your toothbrush every couple of months
yeah months because like yeah every every couple of months
you have to change your toothbrush i thought it was more
frequent than that wait how frequent
How frequent is it supposed to be?
Oh, someone said...
I thought it was, like, every month or so.
Oh, someone said three months, max.
Okay, okay.
I was like, wait, you change your toothbrush every month?
Well, like, I've been getting sick a lot, so I've been
changing it a lot recently.
Not every year?
Not every three to four years?
It's like a mattress.
You're just supposed to flip it upside down.
You're not supposed to get a new mattress.
You just flip it.
Okay, for those who don't know why I had to change my
toothbrush every couple of months, it's because, like, you
know how you're using your bathroom and you're flushing?
Yeah.
If it's all in the same room, you're going to want to
change.
Wait.
Oh.
Is that alive?
Or, hey, hey.
It's a good thing.
Oh, it's a cat.
You don't get to see the cat.
Oh, wait.
There's one next to you.
you he's wait what is happening oh my god he's dying he's
just dying oh my god there's another one there's another one
over here in the universe there's a one under the couch too
wait they're all just dying what's going on dies of cringe
they see us they're like no jokia mentor here they haven't
changed their toothbrush and over So that you have to change
your toothbrush every couple of months because when you're
flushing, you know, you're ingesting that man That's why you
close your mouth.
You open your mouth When what do you mean?
When I brush my teeth, how else do you brush your teeth?
Oh, okay.
It's not like you know when you're flushing you like mouth
open.
Oh, no, I just mouth open over the seat, you know
That's why you gotta...
You gotta change your...
Six!
Where's the other six?
Where's the third six?
You found it?
Six is here!
It's over there!
Six, six, six!
We're gonna make it!
Someone's like, wait, you change your toothbrush?
No!
Oh no!
You don't change your toothbrush until the bristles are all
frayed?
What do you mean?
That's why I don't flush.
No!
Oh, brother.
All right.
Oh, brother is huge.
Brother is huge.
Brother.
Bro, I love how we could tell immediately.
We were like, brother.
Brother.
We're supposed to be the same size.
Brother, you can't drink more milk than us like this.
Come on, man.
Yo, he's been doing too much protein shakes.
Brother, you've been going to the gym without us?
It's not fair.
is going to join basketball he's he's on the hospital oh
we're almost a 16 we're at almost 16 let's go oh my god he's
b okay okay all right all right okay all right brother's the
same height oh yeah no what the hell is that i think it's
following you does it rush over oh wait what is going on oh
wait what stab us i can't Oh, they're growing bigger.
Oh, my God.
It's like a...
Oh, wait.
It's cheesy.
Ah!
Oh, my God.
It's protecting its babies.
Go out, come.
It's protecting the babies.
It's like those...
That was...
It was like bears.
It was a brother.
Yeah.
All right.
Last floor.
Last floor, baby.
Until we're at 400.
How...
Oh, all we have to do is...
The ones who are at 400...
oh yeah definitely what's behind what do you think is over
there i'm gonna look i'm gonna look let's look what is it oh
oh um what is it oh i don't want to die though because i
don't want to redo okay let's go no there was nothing behind
it there was nothing behind it oh there's nothing behind it
yeah you really check you could go look i you don't trust me
come on no i trust you i trust you i just wanted to check i
can't believe you don't trust me you don't trust me you
always look at what the stuff i looked at i hope you don't
die this time again oh yeah sorry for a second Sacrificing
my life for you.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
What's in here?
I don't know.
I just saw, like, PC monitors in the toilet.
Wait.
Oh, we have to open the doors.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
What the fuck?
That was your door.
Wait, but we just restart.
It's fine.
Uh-oh.
Sorry.
Just run away.
What do you...
me oh skippity hey wait actually oh you missed it oh this
one is empty though i can't believe it's a boomer oh it's
flooding it's flooding is that you no that was not me i did
not open why does all the doors you opened end up killing us
it's not me what do you mean it's not you you every door you
just keep opening just keep opening oh who's laughing oh my
god it's not going inside oh no oh no we're gonna drown my
toilet's laughing at me my toilet's laughing at me too oh I
found it I found it you found it where where where are you
come on hurry up oh shit hurry up you don't even say where
we're at and you say hurry up thanks for the instructions
there man Is this the same room?
Oh, no, we're in the toilet now.
Oh, our brother needs privacy.
Brother.
Oh, we're going to have to check inside every single...
I don't think...
Oh, my God, look at us!
That's us!
Family portrait.
Look at family photo in the bathroom, everybody.
Meet us.
Meet and greet in the bathroom.
Six toilets.
There's six of everything.
There's even six sinks.
Oh, my God.
And there's six blowdriers.
Ew, they're right next to the toilet.
They're right, they're gonna blow that into your hand.
Brother, do you have enough toilet paper?
I like how the kids sink is next to the urinal.
Okay, this one's gotta be easy.
There's like nothing in here, right guys?
I think we got this.
Idle meeting time.
We can speed run this to 600.
We can speed run this.
Yeah.
We're literally so close to the end.
I think we're actually, yeah.
We're like masters now.
Oh my god.
We're the masters of the universe.
I don't know about that What do you mean?
The mirror will be fun?
Oh, don't say that.
Don't say that.
How would you know?
Check the mirror.
Oh!
There's more than just blood!
Those hands are like coming out of the wall.
Yeah, like it's like a PNG.
He's holding a PNG of the airmen.
They're supposed to be like a behind the vent.
Wait, does that mean vents are fake?
Like they don't lead anywhere?
There's no ventilation?
Oh my, wait, there's no ventilation in the bathroom?
Ew!
That's not hygienic at all.
All right.
I like how we don't say anything.
We just run around.
Just the 180.
I was like, all right, that's an anomaly, right?
Don't eat.
I have to pee.
Oh, okay, don't worry.
I'll do this for us.
Don't die in there, okay?
Just stay there.
What if I just die?
Don't die!
Why are you still here?
Okay, I'll be right back.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on, guys.
Sorry.
Were you guys waiting to see if I get it?
Oh, okay.
There was no anomalies.
Wait, has there always been three trash cans down here?
Why is there a trash can down here?
I didn't look down, guys.
I didn't...
Guys, has there always been three trash cans?
I didn't look down!
Yeah?
Wait, why would the trash cans be here?
Okay, there's always been three trash.
Two, four.
No, we have to start counting.
Two, four, six.
Two, four.
Wait, where's five?
Two, four, six.
Okay.
Two.
Four, five.
Where's the six?
There's the six broom!
Two.
Oh, there's a two, four, six.
Two, four, six.
2 2 4 where's the 6 trash can 6 okay there's 6 of everything
2 4 5 wait there's 5 so 6 that's a okay 1 2 3 4 5 6 I think
we did it no anomalies no anomalies if we get it wrong I
blame chat there's a 7 urinal there's a 7 urinal I don't
know, two, there's six, you're no, someone can't even count.
All right, I think we're good.
I think there's no, no anomalies.
Well, Min is so slow.
Of course, of course she goes to the bathroom when there's
no anomalies.
Look at her.
Was there, yes, there was six toilets because the whole game
is based off of six, six, six.
So there's six of everything.
Hold on.
Men, don't come over here.
No, men, there's no anomalies.
Get over here.
No, you can't just...
What do you mean you have to get tea?
There's no anomaly.
If only I could just leave.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I could push her.
You're right.
Oh, my God.
Why didn't you guys say that earlier?
I could have just pushed it.
I can't believe it.
I could have done that in the very beginning.
I messed up.
Wait, no?
Okay.
There we go.
All right.
We're getting you to the other side.
Nice.
We did it.
We're professionals.
Okay, I gotta, like, make sure.
Okay.
in case there's there is an anomaly or there's no anomaly as
well okay no all right here we go i'm gaming all right
everything looks the same i'm back oh my god you scared of
shit i had to push you to the other side of the elevator
everything looks good there was you had plenty of time me
out if i'm gonna check i don't try to see what do you mean
we're on the other floor now oh nope oh nope no what do you
mean oh let me double check this is a new floor come on
let's hurry it up i literally pushed you from one elevator
to another
all right here we go was she brave you guys be honest i was
so brave i counted i learned how learn my ABCs.
You took your counting medicine.
Yeah, I took my counting medicine.
Okay.
I just realized we had to count these items as well because,
like... Yeah, how many trash cans were there?
Six?
Okay.
Yeah, it's six.
Oh, seven.
No, there's seven.
Two, four, six.
What do you mean?
You're six.
Someone didn't learn to count.
I didn't learn... It's me!
I didn't learn how to count!
Someone didn't learn two, four, six.
Wait, that's like in every single little Two, oh, four, six,
two, oh, four.
I think we're good.
I think we're good too.
I'm pretty sure.
I think so.
Back to kindergarten.
Mint didn't take her counting medicine.
That's okay.
Send me back to kindergarten.
Let me be a child again.
All right.
Yay, 406.
406.
six four oh six trying to get me out of here six that's
pretty impressive you were able to find me all the way yeah
it was that blow dryers oh my god the blow dryer is it
scared me so bad i couldn't even make a noise i was like
it's just like whoa i thought it was something chasing us we
we talked with shit up on the blow dryers, guys.
Ugh.
Okay.
Alright, we're still normal.
2, 4.
Let's test our counting.
2, 4, 6.
Oh, wait, make sure to look between the toilets, too.
I looked in between.
Why is this toilet, like, filled with...
Was there always a toilet in here?
Yeah, this is, like, the handicap slot, too?
Yeah, because it's the big...
your stall yeah that's so messed up they did not care this
is a hospital there's so many people in wheelchairs and yet
they filled it up look up i'm looking up six i mean we
counted everything there's six lights two four wait no
there's eight lights has there always been eight lights i
don't think it's that meticulous right i don't think so
either yeah yeah there's a bloody handprint what do you mean
bloody handprint everybody's spamming handprint.
Handprint?
Is it in the toilet, maybe?
Anyone spam handprint on your chat?
There are four lights.
What do you mean?
Handprint by the kids' urinal.
There's a kids' urinal?
There's a kids' child.
I don't think there is.
They're just saying that the fuck was...
Oh!
Oh, that's not a urinal.
That's so exciting.
Wait, there's also like a hand there.
Yeah, there's something in the trash can.
Wow, that's sneaky.
Oh, that was a sneaky one.
is it a hand i can't i'm trying to see it was i'm pretty
sure it's a hand we're not short enough to see it we're not
we now know someone in the chat pees in sinks someone uses
the kids urinal the pee in the sink i don't think it's first
is allowed near near the kids hospital someone's peeing in
sinks over here oh in public urinal What if you stand there?
I dare you to stand there.
Stand where?
Over there?
Wait, there's a shadow over there.
Yeah, stand on.
No, I already dared you!
It's gone.
Oh, it's gone.
Oh, it's back!
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, it's back.
That's your turn.
Oh, it's gone.
You, like, absorbed him.
Yeah, yeah, you too.
All right, you too.
Oh, it didn't move it back any further, though.
Yeah, it's just there.
Yeah.
All right.
Anomaly.
We're so good at this.
I know, right?
Oh, my God.
We're like professional anomaly hunters.
even yeah we didn't get help from chat at all like yeah yeah
we got like we've like never failed we literally have never
failed yeah we've had we've been consistent throughout this
this game is just a really long game why do you run past the
door why did you say oh oh brother brother it's okay brother
brother it's okay it's a miracle brother has risen on the
fourth day he rises oh my god oh my god it's a miracle guys
why do you always run oh okay someone peed in the urinals
for me someone actually peed in the urinals they mixed the
juices up what do you mean by that what do you mean by that
only grows on your side I don't think even bros will
understand what you mean only bros no
all right let's see don't run past just run just run inside
what wait there's something weird something weird oh the
caution signs are moving yeah they're coming they're coming
towards us coming after they're actually coming after it
wait what would the cautious eyes do wait let's see but what
if we die they're converging you fucking eat us like
converging they're converging it's like a like mating ritual
we're watching a mating ritual right now oh nope oh i don't
want to i'm not i'm not their mate i'm not their mate come
on it wants a mate i think they'll block the entrance i
think right oh maybe yeah i think they're gonna block the
exit Thank you for the rain.
Oh my god.
Maria, thank you for the rain.
The floor is wet.
From all the juices in the urine open.
Your words, not mine.
See, I told you you knew what it means.
I knew it.
See?
She knows what it means.
Don't run past the door.
Just go straight in.
Don't run past.
I've always, I've always walked in.
No, you haven't.
Literally every time.
She's rewriting.
history right now she's she's rewriting history two four six
there's six trash cans i think it's no anomaly i think this
one's good the i can't i'm looking up are the toilet seats
up or are they normal yeah they've always been up okay it's
a men's urinal the urinals i mean it's a men's
You okay, brother?
There's no doors that's cracked.
What do you mean?
All the doors have been cracked.
Yeah.
Someone was like, saw something.
What did you see?
Did you take your med?
I saw something.
I saw you.
Nothing in the mirror.
There's six of everything.
Are you gaslighting?
No, I'm not.
I'm not.
Wow!
He's like, peek-a-boo.
He's like, probably.
Hello?
I'm lagging!
Oh, Discord.
Discord has been weird today.
Discord's been weird.
No, no, my OBS is lagging.
to oh i think there's a biggie in here i think there's a big
one in here oh no lucky crash oh no i'm okay now i'm okay
okay oh my god it was so scary it was so scary because like
i said that and then like everything just stopped everything
stopped moving and i was like oh no what happened wait are
there more fire things than usual two or four i mean you can
literally count Was there always six?
I mean, there's six of everything, never mind.
Yeah, I mean, I was like, was there always six and six, six?
Oh, my God.
That was so spooky.
Spooky.
Her stream is alive.
My stream is alive now.
Woo.
I think there's nothing here.
There's been, like, not a lot of anomalies for this one.
Not for this one, no.
I mean, it's, like, such an empty room.
What are you going to do?
I think, like, this one's, like, hard.
have anomalies i think so too i think we're fine yeah all
right oh i can't punch you i tried your quota i hit what
happened why can't i punch all the time how come we can't
have six brothers i don't understand we can only have five
brothers but it's a five it goes up to four players where's
our where's our where's brother four five and six we went in
the wrong elevator ah
This was you.
No it wasn't!
No it wasn't you!
You led the way!
This was you!
No, I followed you.
I followed you.
You could have stopped me.
We could have stopped me.
We could speed run!
Handprint.
Don't.
You know.
Check if the thing appears.
Wait, but what if there's new anomalies?
What if there's new ones that we don't?
Oh wait no, this is zero.
This is zero.
Oh this is zero.
You're right.
right no
no this is chat's fault they should have they should have
told us they should have told us they should have laughed at
our jokes because we're just so funny
oh my okay okay okay okay thank you game thank you game
thank you don't worry we can speedrun what four were we on
what how far did we get to oh we got to 13 we We got to 13,
man!
We got to 13!
Oh, oh, oh.
What the fuck?
I dare you.
I triple dog dare you.
I quadruple dog.
You know what?
I'm not afraid!
Oh.
Hey.
Oh, my God.
I killed them.
You murdered them.
You didn't see anything.
You cleaned up the bodies really fast.
Oh, my God.
You didn't see anything.
You killed them.
No, I did not, brother.
Brother, brother.
always been three brothers.
Remember that.
There's always been three brothers.
There's never been a four, fifth, or sixth brother.
What?
Oh, that is the mating ritual again.
Oh, is the mating ritual, you're right.
Here they come.
This is why there's only three brothers.
I'm an accessory to murder.
They won't believe you.
Hey, but that was a new one.
yeah yeah okay all right we got this speed run speed run
speed run speed run speed run speed run we have to be
careful of the head though peaking out yeah but the head i
mean i'll look at it i'm looking at it okay i'm looking at
it okay look through the cracks right now while we i'm
looking through the cracks i'm looking through the cracks
i'm peaking i'm i don't see anything i don't This is why he
doesn't talk.
He saw some stuff he wasn't supposed to.
He saw some stuff.
Amazing ritual.
Okay, check for handprint.
I already looked.
We all looked.
Here we go.
405.
405!
Give it up for 405!
Bing!
Yeah!
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Let's see.
Brother is still on the toilet.
It's so loud.
It's so damn loud.
I never expect it.
No one ever expects the blow dryers.
At least we got it out of the way.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
Everybody, we're okay.
We're okay.
We're almost back to 13.
Brother.
Brother is not performing any miracles.
right now i'm looking i'm checking what what check the doors
wow what the he closed the door stop stop looking at them
stop it stop looking at them she lets you look but i can't
wait were you invited to something i think so i think so But
that was also a new one.
That was a new one.
Oh yeah, that was a new one.
I've never seen that one before.
Yeah, so...
That could have been 14, 15, and 16.
Brother.
Brother's not performing miracles.
No peekaboo.
No peekaboo, no peekaboo.
We're missing like one new anomaly.
I think so too.
Yeah.
No hands.
We can see our faces.
There's no hands coming from the vents.
I think we're fine.
No anomalies.
Okay, cool.
Alright, nice.
All right.
See, we're so good at this.
Let's go.
We could have been at four or five hundred.
We could have been at four.
Shut up.
We'll be there.
We'll be there!
We'll get there.
Okay.
All right.
Brother.
Brother sitting down.
Faces.
Handprint.
All right.
Back to the elevator.
Bro, we got every tween going on now.
I know.
We have a system.
We're speedrunners!
Speedrun.com!
Sign us up!
Maybe don't.
Why are we speedrunning?
Because we...
No, no, because you...
Chat messed up.
Chat.
Brothers, brothering.
We have faces.
There's no shadow footprint.
Oh, there's a peekaboo!
Peekaboo, peekaboo!
All right.
This is the slowest speed run.
What do you mean?
Jaguars, I don't mean you.
What chat are we talking about?
What are you trying to plot?
I think there's only two chats here.
Oh, brother is...
Brother comes after us.
Brother does not just...
Brother runs?
Brother walks you.
Oh my god, a miracle, the second miracle!
Like, what if he came to the door?
What if he was just like, he was trying to talk to us?
He was trying to communicate.
He was like, brothers, brothers, look at me now.
Brothers, this is the one time I'm sentient.
Brothers, I have something very important to tell you.
Oh, it's the footprints.
Oh, it's the foot.
All right.
This is the one time I can say whatever it is.
I've been keeping it in for the entire time.
Oh my god, we're almost there back to work.
one more anomaly that we haven't seen before because we got
uh because we we were missing three and now we saw two of
the new ones yeah we need the we're missing this one's gonna
be the faces nope never mind just kidding nope no urinals i
don't see anything there's no hands coming out of the vent
hey everything at least they don't make us count these i
know god i was not i'm not paying attention i know it's all
sixes but i'm not paying attention We need the...
Alright.
Okay, let's go.
413!
Back where we started!
Yeah, you're right.
Bing!
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
What's this one?
No faces.
No blood in the urinals.
No hands coming out.
Uh...
There's nothing.
Another...
No anomaly?
Two in a row?
Two, four, six.
Come on, ghosts.
You're getting...
Come on.
You're getting a little lazy right now.
Yeah.
Come on.
Okay, whatever.
What is this?
We want an actual challenge.
This way.
4-14.
Yippee!
It has to be the last three.
It has to be the anomaly ones because we're missing the
faces, the hands coming out of the vent and the blood in the
urinal.
Yeah, we're missing those three.
Okay, so, easy peasy.
We got this, guys.
All right, which one is this?
Hands.
Hands, all right.
You know what?
We can let, I bet you, you don't risk it.
We stay in the elevator for the last three.
Stay in the elevator?
Oh, me?
Okay, I'll stay in the elevator.
No, we press the buttons.
We don't even have to look at it because the last two has to
be anomalies.
You're a coward.
What do you mean I'm a coward?
I'm wanting to go into the room.
You know it's an anomaly.
But what if it's not?
What if it's not?
You know it!
Blood in the urinal.
I knew it.
The last one has to be the mirrors.
Okay, then you can check.
It's too risky!
I'm gonna do it.
How much you want to bet?
I will bet money.
How much you want?
I will bet an Aka Super.
You know I'm right!
You're wrong.
Why are you running back this way?
That's why I'm smarting.
I'm gonna die immediately on this one so that...
Oh, what?
Where are we?
We're in a janitor's closet?
Oh my god.
60 seconds in heaven.
Why is it so dark in there?
I don't...
Oh.
No.
No, we gotta go downstairs.
Oh, yeah.
Ah!
Oh!
I think we, like, broke our ankles.
I think we broke our ankles.
Okay, maybe we don't push each other then.
Maybe we can't, actually.
Wait, you can't run?
You can't even run?
I fucking ran and I broke my ankle.
Coming?
There's something going like, I'm like, I like ran and I
broke my ankle.
What happened?
You are weak bones.
happened to you oh my god there's like whispering oh my god
please god no please are you even watching can you see
what's like happening yeah i was born there's a girl
whispering she's humming every breath i take is pain shut up
you weak-willed woman oh my god i'm so close i have bone do
i just walk or oh my god wait there's a face there there's a
face where look at it i i It would be so funny if you look
at it again.
Oh, okay.
I made it.
He's a face, you liar.
Yes, there is!
Why am I the only one that survives these?
Doki, you!
Oh, I'm sorry, my bones weren't made of glass.
Oh, you're gonna fucking bring up my medical history.
Brother has been demoted to being a janitor.
He's a janitor.
Okay, okay, this is always in here, this little head bag.
They're throwing away body parts.
Wait, oh yeah, this little head bag.
Why are they throwing away body parts?
Okay, I don't think...
So many caution wets.
There's six brooms, six...
Six brooms, six...
There's six trash cans.
But there's only five sinks.
Oh, that...
Oh, I feel like that's gonna be an anomaly.
They're just gonna bring a six sink out of nowhere.
And there's five trash cans.
There's five trash cans?
Oh, because this is like four or five hundred.
We're so close.
Mint!
Okay, yeah.
We have 266 floors to go!
We're almost at the finish line!
I did not expect this game to be like three hours long.
I didn't expect that.
Well, you know, if some chatters wouldn't, you know, give us
the wrong information.
Oh, you're so right.
Yes, if some chatters...
If some chatters...
Backseated us better.
Oh!
Oh, God, that actually...
That actually got me.
That actually got me!
That got me, too!
Wait.
Wait, that's the anomaly, right?
It started us over.
No, it's 501.
That's where we were at.
Yeah, so we go up.
That was the anomaly.
Oh, okay, then go up.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
That had to be.
That kind of got me.
I was like, I was like, I just got a new PC last week.
What do you mean?
And I saw 666.
Yeah, you guys, it's the dragoons.
It's not you, don't worry.
Yeah, guys, it's so listed.
You know, it's always so listed.
Go into the rooms.
Oh, good, good, good, good.
Good, it's both of us.
Wait, oh.
Brother, brother, help us, brother.
Brother, brother, brother, brother, brother.
Brother, brother.
Go pink, go.
There's Johnny.
Is he gonna break it down?
okay that was good
yo that was so good that was good if it's the perfectly cut
rectangle in the door that really
blender's rectangle delete all right let's go let's go i
wonder what it would have looked like on the outside i know
right i am pretty cute that was a good one that was a pretty
good that was a good one you know what des you got that you
got you can have that one i don't think there's anything
here i'll see any anomalies the bags all have neither check
the signs if they say any other six six six one yeah oh yeah
every i feel like every floor has a six six they do some
sometimes somewhere six six six how have you been counting
all of these so they're all five all five they're all five
we're on the fifth floor oh my god the 500th the dev is so
funny all right here he goes in the five oh the johnny goes
in the square go on all right there's got to be something in
here caution
nothing is there nothing in the bag something in four or
five there's no sixes anywhere i feel like the sixes would
be like in the trash can you know something yeah yeah yeah
like at the bottom of the trash yeah yeah yeah or somewhere
i don't see any body parts coming out i think we're good i'm
going on the other side okay brother we're good goodbye
brother where are you i was just double checking you don't
you never trust me you're not just checking I was right.
I was like, Okay, if we go to 500, I'm just saying.
The last three floors were anomalies and you didn't trust
me.
You were like, no.
No.
You wouldn't have bet real money into it because you knew I
was right.
You knew I was right.
I was just being cautious.
You know your head bobbles up and down when you run.
Like actual running.
Wait, something seems different.
This?
Was there always where there always that's a way too many
plugs, right?
Yeah, it's way.
I think that's way too many.
Oh, there's six of everything suddenly.
Oh my god, we returned to court.
Oh my god, you're right.
Yeah, six of everything.
I like how you're like, well, look at the plugs.
I'm like, look at everything else.
prepared you focus on the fucking plugs i mean i it's the
first thing i saw i don't know what do i i mean the tiny
plugs of the first not the giant red fire there was just so
many plugs there were look they were covering the wall was
the first thing i saw oh there's a baby oh there is a i
can't I'm dead.
I'm dead.
The baby killed you!
I'm spectating.
The baby killed me.
I'm back.
Don't look at the baby.
And you were judging me when I killed those two girls.
The baby killed me.
It should have killed you.
I was gonna- I was protecting you.
I was protecting you.
Oh, brother is about to explode.
Brother is about to explode.
Oh my god, Lord Brothers of TNT.
Oh, there
he goes.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Goodbye, Brother.
I, he was a brother to me.
Brother was literally, you know that meme of the guy sitting
and he's like super bright?
That's what he's sitting in the little restaurant.
Come inside, what is wrong with you?
Wait, wait, I was, I was waiting for you to see you.
be inside first i was already inside no you were not no you
were not 100 no no check my bud no check my bud time
stampers time stampers i don't think there's anomalies here
i don't think so pretty sure yeah yeah let's go okay wait
only four mobs i don't i think the chat's with us
Nah!
I knew it.
Gaslighting.
Because a real chatter would be like, what?
The head is moved.
You're sure?
Yeah.
It's not moving now.
No, like they're in different positions.
Oh.
Where are they?
Are you sure?
Yep.
I'm 100%.
Oh, you're right.
It's moved up closer.
You're right.
I see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Easy peasy.
I'm so good at this game.
I'm so good.
I like find everything so quickly.
before Doki.
I'm sure.
Yeah, yeah, like the six plugs that you saw too.
There was actually six plugs.
I don't know why that's what you're so focused on.
That's a lot of, that was not six plugs.
How do we get out?
Oh, God, the collision.
The collision.
I can't get out.
I can't.
I'll beat you out.
I can't get out.
I'm going to cut you out.
I'm trying to click through the wall.
I can't push me No, you're not doing anything See, what do
you mean?
See, this is why we Oh, I got out, I got out, I got out,
come on, come on Oh, oh, oh, it disappeared, okay Wow, wow,
you didn't even try See, this is why Only one of us needed
to go inside Oh my god If it was just one of us inside You
still would have needed me.
No, no.
Okay, you can go then this time.
I'll wait.
Hold on.
I'm drinking my tea.
Okay, you're drinking your tea.
I see.
I don't think there's anything here.
What are you laughing at?
I'm serious.
There's nothing here.
It's because you walk in for two seconds and you're like,
nothing here.
Because I have good memory.
I'm like somebody.
Who has got...
Okay, I actually need chat to...
to keep track of who has gotten the most things in this
game.
I swear, face in the mirror.
That's me.
Wait, was there a mirror in that case?
There's no mirror in there.
I got gas lit.
You know when they're lying, when like, they get extra
detailed.
Because, like, usually when they think they see Anomaly,
they'll be, like, mirror.
But then they say, face in the mirror.
I got one guide for real.
Yeah.
one guy yeah five 12.
all right here we go i hope it's an it's a it's no anomaly
so we could you would have gotten through this game without
me like i was i was so good at uh exit eight okay i
literally had a speed run wreck this is literally exited but
multiplayer so i did that solo it's like a different game
two four this is literally exit oh Anomaly.
See, I found it Before you.
Wow.
I found it before you.
Look at that.
You didn't Even see it.
If I said nothing That was actually really good.
I'll give you that one.
You know, I press the button though.
Which means I found it.
If I press the button, that means I Wow.
Who?
What are these like new rules?
She's definitely Kindergarten.
What they invent new rules.
Just so think of it.
Yeah, you were blocking Way view actually so like no i just
couldn't see it because your big head was in the way i don't
think there's anything here see i don't think so either no
anomaly no yeah you don't believe me i'm just checking you
don't believe me oh someone doesn't believe me oh you press
the button okay yeah this is your choice for no anomaly
Five points
Joki, you said it first You said it first You said it first
You said it first You said it first Remember you're wrong
Remember you're wrong You're fucking wrong No, it means that
you found the anomaly But if there was no anomaly
I don't think there's anything here Mint, you know why we
messed up?
We went to the wrong elevator.
We went to the orange light elevator.
No, we didn't.
No, we went to the other one, right?
No, we went.
We went back.
That's what I'm telling you.
And the rules are too confusing for this game.
That the orange light needs to be more obvious.
It needs to be It needs to be more obvious, I'm telling you
The orange How much more obvious Do they need to be?
The orange Nightlight needs to be like So bright It needs to
be on fire They need signs, they need signs where it just
Has like big like It says you came here You came Anomaly
here.
No anomaly here.
Oh, it's the bag heads.
It's the bag heads.
I found it.
Yeah, put the...
The one you fucked up.
It was you who fucked up, not me.
Oh, yeah.
Someone should stay outside for Johnny.
You're right.
Someone...
Oh, yeah, you're right.
You're right.
all right i'll be outside i want to see johnny oh rock paper
scissors rock paper scissors i think i think there's no
anomaly here but you can check don't don't go that way don't
go that way i was just testing you to see if it's like three
in a row i can't believe we got we were so close we were at
5 14
Oh my god This is why this game is gonna take us three plus
hours This is why I don't think there's enough Johnny Johnny
yes, Papa Johnny Well, you gotta wait for me No, I was able
to get out You can do, come on How?
Push the boxes Go outside and push the boxes inward I pushed
them out Outwards you can do it too.
Come on.
Just use your legs.
What do you mean?
I'm using I'm too tall I'm sorry for being six foot seven
Says on my tinder profile six foot seven Well, I'm gonna
wait in the elevator for your lazy ass.
Oh my okay.
It's good All right, here I am.
Oh my god I'm getting there I'm going as fast as my six foot
seven legs start taking me you have really short legs as you
have the white his torso in history.
Alright.
Five, oh fuck.
Eight more to go.
Why is it always on 13 that we mess up?
I know.
I think we get too comfortable.
13 is an unlucky number.
Oh, brother.
It's brother.
It's a TNT brother.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Please, brother!
Think of your children!
Oh.
all right here we go he wants a quick elevator yeah he's a
creeper don't call our brother a creep what's wrong with you
oh my god what are you talking about he still has children
that doesn't make him a creep at all amazing all right I
don't think there's any anomaly here oh I don't think so
either unless there's a new one oh that's true we didn't
think of new ones I think in general it doesn't Yeah, I
think we're good.
I need sixes on the...
Wait, wait, wait!
Anomaly!
Oh, anomaly!
You're right!
The six, six, six!
I knew it!
I knew the six would come back.
I knew it.
See?
Guys, remember the competition that Mint proposed where
whoever catches the most anomalies wins?
What a competition!
I just said who has the most?
This competition that Mint really wanted to do where she was
like, oh, guys, time's down every time.
Like, whoever picks the anomaly.
Okay.
um i'm still winning doki got like three in your dreams i
guess i like how you like don't even walk inside no because
we wanted to see johnny oh yeah remember trying to get
johnny how could you forget about johnny yes papa yes papa i
don't think there's nominees i don't think so either yay
finally the closer one yay every time i was like but um i
feel like we're saying oh we missed it wait what was there
what huh oh that was you you called it no i did that was you
called it you called it you called it you called it you
called it you called it you gotta be stuck in for 500
forever the door was backwards wait how what do you mean the
door how can the door be backwards okay this is the this is
the oh yeah this is the yeah that's right I always forget
it.
We're gonna be stuck in floor 500.
I could tell you were hydrating before the cry.
Oh, it was on the wrong hinges.
Oh my God, so that's something else we have to wait.
Why don't they keep track of the wrong hinges?
So right now, oh no, yeah, right now.
Yeah, yeah, right now.
It's backwards.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh good, we got it out of the way.
got yeah we got that that is such a sneaky one that is well
that should have been a floor 516 one right there not stupid
people missed that too yeah everyone is probably missed that
in their lives yeah everybody those who called it out has
played this game before i could tell johnny johnny yes it's
um all the plugs all the plugs oh yeah it's uh It's all the
plugs.
We're stuck in 500 forever.
We'll never get this.
He was right.
The death was right.
We will never get 666.
We're stuck here forever.
It's Chad's fault.
They didn't warn us soon enough.
They could have yelled at us.
They really could have.
They could have screamed if they knew it instantly.
I was going to say, I was going to say Aka Supa.
That's what it seems so mean.
It seems so mean.
Come on!
Are you...
Come on, miss!
Okay, I'm coming!
I'm coming!
Don't push me back any pictures!
Oh, look at me, I actually got out, so clearly it was just a
skill issue for you.
Oh yeah, it's not like I helped you get there.
Look out when you pushed me out!
Are you pushing me out?
I don't know what you're talking about.
you get there guys guys if you guys see any anomalies make
sure the akasuba we will totally see and we won't miss it at
all yeah the yo sixes no there's no anomalies yeah guys this
is your chance right now we're saying there's no anomalies
this is your chance i'm gonna look at everything really
slowly i'm gonna look at this really slowly no anomalies if
there was anomaly it's not our fault we gave you a chance no
elf no elf no elf all right here we go up we go bing we go
bing 505 505 johnny johnny johnny johnny johnny what if we
both have to be inside though No, I don't think so.
Because, like, what if it's a solo single player?
A single player, it wouldn't matter.
Yeah, because they would be inside.
No, wait, what?
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Okay, dokey.
Alright.
No anomalies.
No, we have to go to the further one.
No!
Maybe it'll give us back-to-back no anomalies.
She's an actual bird.
what what does that say about you huh you messed up too you
have not as much as yeah at least people can say i'm a bird
brain what about you then i'm dead i have like my brain is
ectoplasm it's literal mush okay oh smileys smileys okay
back to the long one we go back to the long one don't worry
i'll speed you up i'm gonna speed you up actually you're
really not doing anything
it's like i'm getting a massage i'm a chiropractor not
licensed all right next one guys we're so close to 513 again
are we we're gonna make it are we that close we're i don't
know oh it's the head yeah yeah yeah that's the bags At
least the shoes running is kind of ASMR.
Yeah, it is.
You know, when it says hospital 666, I honestly thought the
6 was a joke.
Wait, so do we get to, like, what happens?
Do we get to just floor 6?
Or do we do this?
No, it's 666, so it could be like 613, like 615, and then
all the way to 666 at the end.
Okay, great.
Johnny.
No, Johnny.
Oh, it's the 666.
Okay.
Back to the long hallway we go.
You didn't even go into the room.
We want to see the Johnny.
Yeah, but what if you have to come inside?
Well, if we have to go inside, I would have gotten inside to
see if we triggered the Johnny.
The Johnny.
That Johnny, that silly guy.
He's so silly.
I want to see him too, though.
Alright, I'll go inside.
We'll do Russian roulette again.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, one of us has to get the baby and the other one
gets Johnny.
me inside push you inside we get the um pov of johnny again
fred rose seats i'm gonna get really close to him yeah
johnny we want to see you we'll see your face whoa whoa whoa
there's johnny
there he is here here's johnny i like how i grew up laugh.
Oh my god, someone Akka stupid me and said, I see an
anomaly!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
Oh my god, thank you!
I never would have got...
Oh, brothers on fire, brothers on fire, brothers on fire!
Why is it always the long one when brothers on fire?
I don't know.
this game is breaking us we didn't think we didn't realize
when they said six to six it was literally six six hours you
remember when we said 24 hour stream we were not joking i
guess we meant it oh it's the baby it's the baby it's the
baby it's the baby i went the Don't go the wrong way.
I can't...
Oh, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Push me faster.
Baby, baby, baby.
The baby.
I think we didn't look at the baby, so the baby's not
coming.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's stupid baby.
He gone.
Yeah, stupid baby.
That's why you're a baby.
You should have died.
You should have died by the baby this time.
Why was I?
Why was I supposed to die by the baby?
Because I died from the baby last time.
Yeah, but you're stupid.
Yeah, because totally I knew that looking at a baby would
kill me.
I told you I'm not ready to be a mother.
Well, I saw that Tokyo jungle play through.
You were so ready to be on.
You should play that game.
You should build.
You saw me that I killed, like, your little birdies.
Was there anomaly?
Why are you just standing back there?
Because there was no anomaly.
What are you doing?
Oh, my God.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
I almost did it.
What are you doing?
There was no Akasupa, so she couldn't tell, guys.
I know, you guys.
I was the Akasupa, but I did it for free.
The way you were standing in the hall was so menacing.
What haven't we gotten?
I was like, what is she doing?
No way.
There has to be an anomaly in here.
There's no anomaly.
no no guys we're waiting we're waiting for the akasupa right
now wait wait there's something on the floor is that oh
we've been like that yeah it's a face on the floor it is oh
shit it's salad fingers they we got something new we're
going past 4 5 13 we went past it yay new record
What does it say about you?
You recognize these references.
You recognize the references too.
There hasn't been anything with Brother yet.
I mean, there was one where he grew taller, right?
Oh, no, no, he exploded.
Just kidding.
Yeah, he exploded.
Why did the Brother explode?
Why did he explode?
Not just one.
I don't think there's actually one in here.
I don't think so either.
I don't see anything.
There's no faces on the floor.
And someone gave me a blue super chat and was like, Aka
soup.
Wait, does that mean there's an anomaly or there's no
anomaly?
Does blue mean safe?
Let's move.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Swipe or no swiping?
All right.
Okay, this is the right.
This is the correct elevator.
Yep, yep.
Because there's no anomalies.
There's no anomalies.
Why are you having me press it?
You made up the rule!
You are the one that made up the rule!
5.15.
5.15, you guys.
Has there been one that we haven't done yet?
That we haven't saw?
I think we haven't...
Oh, this one.
It's this one, yeah.
It's the blue screen.
This was the first one we got, I think.
So it was long time ago.
Yeah, and then it, like, threw us off because we fire who
was real.
5.16.
And I think we haven't gotten the one with the...
Lots of plugs, right?
No, we did.
You're the one that called it out.
Wasn't that on the previous run, though?
Oh, you're right.
Wait, you're right.
Oh, you're right, yeah.
Or did we?
I can't remember.
Everything's blending together, you guys.
All these floors we went through, so many floors.
No, no.
I don't know, actually.
Brother?
I don't know.
Brother, we don't know.
Brother, help, brother.
I think there's nothing here.
Are you sure?
Oh, you're trusting me now?
No, I meant I'm not trusting you.
Brother.
I'm sure.
Guys, I don't know.
If we fuck up, we go back to zero.
All the way to zero.
If we go, guys, you don't want to go back to zero, guys.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh, you press it.
Wait, why am I pressing it?
Because I pressed it last time.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Come on.
I can't look.
SCP.
You.
What?
No.
Chat.
Why did we miss?
There was no anomalies.
Did we go to the wrong elevator?
No, we didn't.
No, no, we didn't.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
This is the first level.
Oh, wait.
Someone said review.
We can go review it.
Who did we do?
Okay, now we have to review.
No way.
She said you missed.
What is it?
No anomalies.
It wasn't the door.
We got that one.
It was like the first one we got.
Nobody super chatted us.
No smiley.
No one else noticed.
Nobody noticed.
Anything in the trash?
245, 245, 245, 245.
5.
245.
There's...
Is it like a time thing, like with the head, you know?
Like we weren't looking in the right direction.
Someone said...
Under the shelf?
Is it this box?
The...
That thing looks weird.
Oh my god.
What?
Look up.
Up?
Wait, wait, up?
Look up.
Look up?
Here?
Oh, no.
Are you kidding me?
Do you see it?
Is it the 666666666?
Look up.
Look up at the box, too.
It's this box right here.
Look.
They said look up.
There are 666 labels.
Oh, my God.
Here too.
Chat didn't know either chat didn't know what there was no
super chat chat didn't know either you can't blame it on us
Apparently there's like oh all the bottles say six six six
two Oh they used to say ethanol and um I thought there would
only be one six six six because it's the trash They they
beat it us they've always they've always did one and now
it's like several now it's two This is messed up.
This is messed up.
It's not our fault, guys.
It's never the streamer's fault.
One chat member got the labels right.
No, this is so messed up.
One guide in the correct direction.
The one guide was actually correct.
What is this?
And on the final thing, on the final one!
That was so cheesy!
That was so, that was so cheap.
Oh my god, that was so cheap.
We were so happy getting to the sixth...
100 forever.
It's okay.
We can speed run.
We know everything now.
We know them all.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Speed run, speed run, speed run, speed run.
We knew everything.
Okay.
What is it?
Uh, six, six, six on the, on the, on the, on the.
Wrong elevator.
I saw you.
I saw you run over there.
Okay.
We got this.
Wait, what, 666 was it?
Was it on the trash can or the labels?
It was on the trash can.
Okay, okay, I'm keeping track so we can, like, if we get all
the anomalies left, then we can just press...
Oh, okay, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice,
nice, nice.
Not us being, like, so excited for some of these.
We're going to have to get the box went all over again, too.
Oh, no.
All right.
I know how to do this faster.
How one person goes?
Yeah.
Okay.
There I go.
Because I'm not a damn big...
It's gonna force you in here once there's Johnny.
It's the bags.
There's a bag.
See?
Look at how fast it is.
So I can just press the button when you're...
Once I'm here.
What if it's not?
What if it's nothing?
What if you have to go all the way back?
I'm gonna lie to you at some point.
I'm gonna tell you that it's...
We all wanna leave the hospital.
If you lie...
It affects you, too.
Here we go.
The boxes.
I'm coming out.
No, really?
I'm leaving.
I'm getting out of here.
Really?
I'm coming out.
Wait, I thought you were an expert on this.
What happened?
I'm coming out.
Yeah, any second now.
Do you see the boxes like getting pushed from the fruit?
I'm coming out I'm coming out The foxes are gonna disappear
soon I'm coming out I'm coming out You see I'm kicking them
one by one I'm coming out Oh Disappeared, didn't it?
No, it didn't No, I punched my way out I punched my way out
You could not do it yourself
Oh my god Oh my god There we go I'm on my way because you
got this donkeys too a bunch of a baby I am not a baby.
I am trying to be efficient here.
I am not a baby.
I'm not a baby I think wait, hold on.
Let me check the labels.
No, not many.
Okay.
Smilies, smileies, smileies, smileies.
Smilies on the light switch.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh my god.
We fucked up be like four times right no it was like three
it was like three this is now you can count i think this is
our third run now you can count oh no actually you don't
this is our fourth run this is actually for real no way yeah
i'm with you this time because i think it's not it's no
anomaly time i think you're right um i'm double checking
everything okay you're right and you see i'm so good
gambling probability wise i was right this game okay oh my
god it's so intense oh brother is exploding brother is
exploding time it's the close one all right exploding
brother goodbye we're missing the label six the label the
baby the six plugs and the the body heads Wait, the labels,
the baby, the floor, oh, the face.
Face on the ground, salad fingers.
No label.
See, I'm helping now.
Yeah, because we're close.
Now we have to go all the way to the other one, yeah.
Yeah, I think we're good.
All the way down.
The hinges, yep, that's correct.
Okay, whoo, that one was before, yeah, I'm used to checking
it on the way to running there.
Yeah, we got Johnny.
Okay, meet Johnny.
Don't forget the floor.
We're good.
Unless...
I think it like slowly starts to appear though.
So we might have to like...
Wait a second.
Which one?
The floor?
Yeah, like it's like the fade in.
Like the QR code.
Oh, like the QR code, yeah.
Yeah, I'm checking all.
Um...
Labels.
Nothing on the floor.
The labels are disinfected.
Yeah.
Do we got the...
Do we get the heads out the trash can yet?
Yeah, we already got that one Oh, okay, so we don't care
about that So I think we're good I think we're good Yeah No
anomalies Check the door Door is good Door is good Okay
We're good We're getting better It only took us four tries
But we're getting better now Yes Oh, my god Bing Yes Okay
Oh, baby Baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby Baby
Alright, we got baby out of the way.
We're still missing Johnny floor labels.
Johnny floor labels.
We got trash bag.
Wait, what was trash bag?
Oh, the one that, yeah, the trash bag that moved.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby.
Oh, Johnny!
It's Johnny!
Holy shit.
I want him to look at me this time.
His eyes kind of look to the right.
You're right.
What's wrong with us anymore?
We need to get to floor 666, you guys.
Please help us, help us.
Oh, the door hinges.
We also got to worry about the door hinges.
666 labels.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Are you okay?
You sound like you're crying.
I think the door hinges are going to be like the last one,
man.
There's nothing on the floor.
Wait, what are we missing?
Oh, the floor?
We're missing the floor.
We're missing the door hinge.
The door hinge.
And also the one of all the extra plugs.
Yeah, there's nothing, so I think we're good.
I think we're good.
back to there we're back to there we still have a whole
other floor we still have three more why did you suggest
this I did why did you agree to this 14 14 no it's not the
door hinge okay last three right I think so last three so
it's all anomalies this one uh unless it's the floor it's
the floor it's the floor it's all three so it's all how much
you want to bet do you really want to do this do you really
want to do this it's all not it's literally all anomalies
you know i'm right okay okay we'll do it we'll do it you
know i'm right okay we're missing we're missing the door
hinge yeah and we're we can see from here we can see from
here it's the six plugs how much you want to bet okay do it
it's the six plugs okay do it Yeah do it do it.
I'm gonna do it do it.
It's the six plugs.
All right.
The moment.
Do it Do it.
And it's the door hinge.
I can see it.
Yeah, I can see it.
Oh my god.
I'm in the back room.
I'm in!
AHHHHH!
Is it me?
It's me, it's me!
I'm literally the sacrifice!
Where's the- I'm trying to find it!
He's chasing me!
I don't know what to do!
Oh, oh my god.
It's after me!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, no.
Wait!
It's to the left!
That's the door!
No, I can't get in!
I can't get in!
That's literally the door!
No!
He has to break it!
He has to break it first!
What is this bullshit?
How do we lead him to that?
Oh my god, you could clutch this!
How do I do it?
OMG!
Oh my gosh!
offended me!
I'm gaming!
You're gaming!
Gamob the year!
Why do I always survive?
Did he just sigh?
Did he just go, hmm?
oh my god 600 600 baby 600 600 we're almost there oh brother
brother brother okay it's the operation room wow there's a
lot going on in here oh my god okay there's a lot going on
in here there's another x-ray over here that we can't go in
okay there's x-rays there's uh there's a calendar here
there's Nice.
Okay, I think I absorbed everything in.
Okay.
There's a computer, the screen is off.
Final stretch, baby.
Okay, let's just do it.
Let's just do it.
We'll learn as we go.
That's how we did it in floor 500, baby.
Why can't this one be in the middle of the room?
All right.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Brother.
brother all the screens are off nothing no sixes anywhere um
i think it's no anomaly oh my god why am i glitching so bad
i don't see any anomalies anywhere oh yeah me too oh whoa
whoa is that a glitch or is that an anomaly is that anomaly
i think oh oh i'm i'm glitching so much even now Whoa!
Whoa!
I think that's an anomaly!
Is that an anomaly?
Oh my god.
Whoa!
YET!
There's no way!
I mean, we're in six of one!
.
Yeah, it doesn't matter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That has to be an anomaly.
That has to be.
I like that one.
That was a cool anomaly.
Yeah, I thought we were lagging.
We do.
Whoa.
Oh, brother scares me every time, man.
Oh, that was a...
a creative anomaly though yeah that one's fun yeah because
you can't tell a bit kuso gay or yes
me june july we care about your health i'm looking up
history nothing i don't see anything i don't see anything
either i think we're actually good this time here we go door
on the wrong side no oh oh don't mess like that i'm checking
now though i'm checking i'm checking i'm checking i'm
6.03.
And the labels, yeah.
We have to check the labels too, just in case.
Yeah, just to see if there's any sixes.
BING!
603, BING!
603, baby!
Let's go!
I think Brother's gonna be standing at one point.
He's gonna freak us out.
Or he's gonna change his face.
Okay, he's fine right now.
Hmm.
Nothing on the monitors.
Nothing on the side.
Nothing in the operating.
No 666 anywhere.
We care about your health.
Main June, July, it's the same date.
History.
There's no way that there's nothing here.
I don't know.
We could get two in a row.
No anomalies.
I guess so.
That's the secret one.
No anomalies for twice.
I don't think so.
All right.
Wait, did they not hear that?
Hear what?
Wait, what?
They're fucking with you.
There's no way they're fucking with you.
What was that noise?
Wait, what do you mean?
I don't hear anything Oh, that's you That's me They said
hole on the bed What There's always been a hole here What
hole?
There's always been a hole there What hole?
What hole?
This hole?
The opera Was that a girl?
What?
I'm scared now What?
That's always been there Oh, this hole here, yeah been there
what do you mean hold on
wow very realistic look we've been playing for for almost
four hours i can't dedicate a voice okay anyway all right up
we go i mean we're at 603 there's no way at best we retry
three floors it's true true true true true it's better than
okay let's see if there's a hole on the bed let's see there
was no hole on the bed there's no hole
we were like there's always been all we were thinking of
like a fucking chiropractor i was thinking massages i forgot
this is an operating table do have holes in the bed.
Sometimes they have holes, right?
Yeah, but brain surgery.
I don't know.
Wait, I don't know about that.
I thought it was there to keep your head comfy.
Me too.
Okay, well, now we know.
Whoa, whoa, what's the game?
The game!
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
Whoa, it's us.
Oh, it's you.
It's my POV.
Yeah.
It's your POV.
Alright, now we know.
Okay.
Guys, at least it was like three floors.
Now we know.
And then we call chat crazy.
We're like, guys, there's always been a hole.
I'm new crazy.
I'm the protagonist.
And they were like, literally, they were like, there's a
hole there.
We're like, oh, yeah, they're always asking.
We said it so confidently.
I know.
We were so like, yeah, duh.
Of course there's a hole.
Oh my God.
All operating tables.
have a hole in it yeah may tune july history I don't think I
see anything here history mm was there brother six six six
brother I think been doing this for a while now brother
brother brother brother brother oh brother oh brother okay
but like also chat was gaslighting us while telling us
there's a hole yeah they were saying exactly that we think
that everything is wrong there's no sixes oh is there
anything on the other side you care about your health care
about your Meiju and Jalele.
The labels are normal.
The x-rays are normal too.
Oh, there's...
There's no hole on the wall this time.
I thought I heard, like, a beeping, but it might have been,
like, just ambience.
Yeah, I think it's ambience.
I didn't hear a beeping.
Okay.
We go to the other side.
No clue.
All right.
No, it's not your fault, Jess.
The home is...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it wasn't your chat that pointed it out.
You know and you chose to ignore it you chose to ignore it
You chose to ignore it All your all that your chest said was
you hear the noise My chat actually called the hole the
fence They probably heard me like humming And we're just
like uh-oh We that wasn't normal It was they were just
trying to be helpful They were just trying I don't what I
don't see anything I can't see vitamin complex there's no
666 we care about your health may june july any heads pop up
uh door hinges are good um wait see if there's lag oh yeah
no no lag no lag so here is it none the floor what about the
floor what about the floor gaslighters don't gaslight oh my
god the wire Say 666!
666!
I saw it before you.
No, I saw it.
I trust my chat.
I saw it on my chat.
That is...
I noticed that they were in perfect circles, but I thought
he just copied and pasted them.
I thought he was being a lazy dev.
After 600 floors, this is the part where he gets lazy.
Don't worry, Wisps.
I know you guys saw it first.
No, don't worry, Dragoons.
I knew you...
When you guys said 666, I knew you.
good i knew you guys were right because i trust my chat yeah
holding the bed holding the bed all right we know holding
the bed is gone yeah holding the bed is gone everybody we
got holding the bed out of the way we were so fucking
confident we were like schooling our chat be like what
there's no there's always holding the bed 606 oh my god
that's 10 away i mean wait oh my god Wait, what?
I was going to say 10 away from 666.
Yeah, I was going to say, like, wait.
Wait, look, look, brother!
Brothers being polite.
Oh my god.
Brother?
What is he?
Brother is talking to someone, I think.
Oh, brother.
Okay, we're going.
Brother.
Brother's been in this hospital a bit too long.
Brother finally is speaking.
It's okay, brother.
Up we go.
He looks like really kind of...
He's slaying right now.
flirty with whoever he's talking to he's like hey i know i
like i want that anomaly again if we fuck up before i can't
wait to get flirty brother back i miss flirty brother um
there's ryden in the operating room what the is that i don't
know i'm there i triple dog dare you to go see him yeah go
up to him we gotta do this again if we No, not necessarily.
Wait, he just...
She's like half clipped to the floor.
What's she gonna do phase through and kill me?
She might.
I'm leaving.
Oh.
What happened to moral support?
I never said that.
Oh, now you're not gonna support me morally.
I've never supported you morally.
I'm not...
Alright.
ride and turn off the game console all right 608 we're
getting there we're
missing the monitor oh there's a baby in the there's a baby
there's a baby in the there's a child baby you need out he's
not moving baby oh wait wait what he's counting he's
counting down he's 93 92 92 we have like a hundred seconds
we have like a hundred seconds why does he sound like that
though 95 94 93 somebody put baby in the corner 609 baby
well hopefully there's no baby all right we got one baby
every floor has a baby no no nothing in the monitor lagging
are you i think so i'm not oh maybe my game i'm not i think
it's because i bumped into you maybe oh maybe yeah i'm okay
i'm walking back and forth okay okay never mind um do you
care about your health may june july disease history i don't
see anything i don't see anything either nothing on the
labels all the labels are not 666 Um...
I think we're fine.
Yay, we're at the closer door!
We're at the closer x-ray!
I'm trusting you, I'm trusting you.
Okay, then you go back into the room then.
I'm scared.
You go back into the room.
You're gonna trust me and you're not confident enough.
I'm scared, I don't know, I'm nervous.
I feel like usually the things are...
I don't know.
Okay, people are like blood, but like, they're not even
confident about it.
They're saying, like, is that blood by the brother, but I
don't see anything at all.
I don't know what...
There's blood by the brother?
I don't think so.
I think they're...
They're being way too specific.
Yeah, there's blood.
What are you talking about?
Where?
Behind the brother?
There's...
No blood anywhere.
A blood by the...
Are we really...
On the cabinet door?
What?
Okay, I'm sure you're pretty sure.
I'm so confused.
I am...
I am confused too.
Huh?
I'm trying to see.
I'm trying to look around to see if we miss anything.
Blood inside you.
That's a medic bag.
Alright, that's ectoplasm.
Yeah.
Get it right.
Okay.
hopefully oh my god okay i mean we get this right at 6 10.
okay we just just rip off the band-aid man just rip off the
band-aid what just
happened oh oh um hello where are you where are you i'm in
exit eight no way you're in exit eight yes i'm in exit eight
you're in I want to get teleported.
I'm in Exit A2.
Oh, hey.
No way.
Keep left.
Oh, shoot.
Aren't we supposed to go backward if it's a...
We go back.
We go backwards.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's actually Exit A.
Oh, my God.
We got Ezekai to Exit A.
Oh, we're back.
Wait, you were back?
Okay.
I think that's an anomaly, guys.
I don't know about that one.
Is it the same dev?
No, it's a different dev.
It's a parody.
That's so funny.
We got Isokai to exit.
Some of these, some of these, like, anomalies are pretty
good, actually.
Yeah, they're actually pretty funny.
Oh, wait.
I think I'm lagging.
I think this is lag.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, is it?
Unless we just pushed each other weird.
Okay, I'm going inside.
I'm lagging.
No, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, I'm trying to get out.
I tried.
Let me out.
I see it pushes me so hard.
Oh, yes.
Oh, I still can't believe I teleported to Exit 8.
I know, that was crazy.
You didn't even want to join me.
I went in.
Okay.
It's 366.
I'm not paranoid.
for any 666 references i know right oh my god ever since
room 515 i'll never forget 515 never forget 516 i'll never
forget 516.
this one looks good i think yeah i think so too anything
behind the brother just for chat's sake where's the blood
okay all right i think we're good yeah yeah All right,
heading to the other side.
No, we have to head to the other side.
Don't you check the labels, right?
You check the labels?
Sure.
Time to look at the numbers.
Time to look at the...
This is your fault.
You said you checked!
That's my mom!
We're reviewing, we're reviewing.
Oh my god.
We're not getting stuck.
We're not getting stuck here.
What was it?
No, they're fine.
These are the x-rays?
Were they supposed to be closer together?
The calendar?
We care about your health.
I think that's what it says.
Is the x-ray supposed to be closer together?
What was it?
There's nothing up top.
Wait, actually.
The plugs?
Wait, what do you mean the plugs?
Oh my god.
Oh, hey.
Oh, it's the walls.
It's the walls.
Oh my god, I just saw them!
It's so...
That is so cheeky!
Oh my god.
It wasn't...
Oh, my...
It doesn't appear until...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, they're making it really obvious.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I kept blue didn't see that.
oh my god oh my god it's because they don't appear soon
enough oh they don't appear soon enough man oh no all right
go to the other speedrunners bane zero this is zero yeah
just keep going keep going give it up for the four hours
we're gonna make it god you're actually you're actually
right it's almost been four four hours of this game give it
up for our number four
okay we got majority anomalies this time yeah it's true it's
true well we get to see we get to see flirty guy again oh
yeah we got to see flirty brother again i miss flirty
brother yeah but it's this it's the same win it's the walls
it's the wall wait it's the walls are you sure oh you're
right yeah it is it is it it's the walls good good good we
got it out of the way I was like, are my eyes deceiving me
because we went through that?
Oh my god.
In another world, there would have been like five floors
left in another world.
Why couldn't they be the first one last time too, right?
Anomaly, anomaly, come over here.
Oh, I see it.
I saw it.
Then monitor.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey, we get to do Exodate again.
Oh, yeah.
That was fun.
Yeah, I wonder if it would be the same one.
The same anomaly with the poster.
Oh, maybe.
Probably, right?
I think it's probably.
Yeah, probably.
Unless they coded, like, several.
The one I don't want, I don't like the lagging one.
It hurts my brain.
Oh, the lagging one was freaky.
There's no 666.
Because we're missing some anomalies that we haven't got.
Yeah, there's a few.
So, like, I'm worried.
But I think this one's okay.
Yeah, I don't think, yeah, I think this one's okay.
I think we're good.
Yeah.
To the next floor!
To the next!
Floor!
I won.
Discord lag.
All right, here we go.
I didn't realize this was like competition, but I'm okay.
You held your note for a long time.
I assumed that we were trying to beat you.
I mean, that's what you would assume, isn't it?
No 666 on the floor.
No baby.
baby and nothing no hole in the no hole in the in the bed
yeah I think we're fine I think we're good yeah we're good
are we are you yeah ceiling what's wrong with the ceiling
i'm checking the always say ceiling they never stop with the
ceiling all right here we go here we go we're so close so
five more than 10 left 11 left go go go go go brother it's
fine nothing no cables everything's fine no sixes of care
about your house labels are fine may june july no history
ceiling nothing it says exit here I think we're good.
There's no hole in the wall.
Let's go.
Really?
Two in a row?
Two in a row.
The game's being nice to us.
Let's go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
I'm worried about the one thing that's like, because we
haven't seen three anomalies.
Yeah, I know.
So it's like... We don't know what to expect.
What to expect.
606!
Yes!
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
It's...
See brother!
Wait, no, never mind.
No.
Oh, it's the monitor, it's the monitor.
Oh, the monitor, you're right.
Again, didn't we get the monitor before?
Uh, there's two different ones, right?
There was?
I think so.
Why did we not?
I thought we already did the brother.
I'm not the brother.
The monitor?
Yeah, I thought we already did the monitor already.
It's your smoker baby!
I think the next one will be the baby.
Baby in the corner!
Baby!
there is too nice okay yeah because i was like i don't
remember seeing two oh no baby in the floor it's a cable
it's a cable oh six six six six six why can't it be the
closer elevator god damn it god damn it give us a closer one
wow someone's so slow today no i have a bug that's flying in
my face oh no there's a there's a bug no about six six six i
killed it oh whoa with your hand it just now.
Is it a ghost bug?
It is now.
Nothing here.
Oh, it's a lady!
It's Ryden!
Ryden!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Turn off the game console!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're doing it.
We're doing it.
We're speedrunning!
We're so good now!
Woo!
6-0-9!
seven more!
Oh my god.
Punching you so we get to faster.
Zesty brothers, Zesty brothers, Zesty brother.
Nope.
Baby?
Hole in the bed.
We punch each other to get ourselves.
We didn't get to six, six, six!
We were like, okay, we found it.
Go, go, go, go, go!
Come on.
There we go.
If you failed the exit 8, do I lose?
I don't know.
Like before, right?
Yeah, yeah, because we got it right before.
We still have the lag.
No, baby.
Again?
Wait, the camera.
What the fuck?
Oh, oh, I saw it.
I saw it.
Oh, that's weird.
Oh, my God.
That's so weird.
That's like the camera, the dead POV.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's kind of fun.
Yeah, that's fun.
All right.
Someone needs to work out more there.
at it.
I was looking at it.
Do not want to leave the hospital.
I'm enjoying my time.
It's literally a camera.
Alright.
Zesty brother, Zesty brother, Zesty brother, Zesty brother,
Zesty brother.
Baby in the corner, baby in the corner, baby in the corner,
baby in the corner.
Baby in the corner!
Okay.
We just have brother and exudate.
I think that's all the ones we've seen, right?
Yeah.
99 Are you?
I was like, where did you go?
92 91 90 89 87 86 What happens when he counts the zero?
That's what I'm wondering.
I'm really curious.
I swear to guy.
I swear to god, many of you have to go back to the 60.
Will it be a Wednesday?
You want me in the elevator?
Come on.
You want me in the elevator, Taki?
You go on.
Go closer to that room.
Go closer.
What did he say?
Oh, is he not?
What do you say?
He's not counting anymore.
He's not clouting.
I don't think he expects us to save you.
I don't think he does.
He got lazy.
I'm telling you, lazy dev, lazy dev.
He doesn't even fucking count all the way to the end.
Call him again start from 10 I know right?
The dev got tired.
It was like when you're supposed to be gone.
Oh yeah exit.
Exit.
Okay I'm gonna see if you no, no, no no, no, no, no.
What?
Oh so you pop into existence.
Oh okay okay I can do that.
Oh my god it's an anomaly.
I gotta go back.
Is it the same one?
Yeah it's the same one.
Oh okay.
Let's see how it would you look like we pop back in There I
go Where are you I'm coming back Oh I'm here
It's this way Oh they say He's popped Okay Up we go Three
more Oh we're missing Zesty brother And then I think two
others right Yeah two others We haven't seen before Oh and
lags I don't think we've gotten the lag one.
Oh yeah, we didn't ever got the lag one!
Okay, so then what is...
We have one anomaly that we haven't got before.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I got this.
We got this.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
What is it?
Look, look.
It's like unfinished textures.
No textures.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, everything has to be anomaly now.
Everything's a PNG.
No, no.
Okay.
Fourteen.
Oh wait.
No.
i think it's better to yeah we're missing one because we
have we have done two yeah yeah we have to check all right
okay it's fine lazy dev my immersion this isn't a video game
this is real life i'm stuck in the game please help stuck in
the hospital zesty brother zesty brother he's having a good
time okay nice okay lag and then unknown yes all right up we
go not we didn't take the wrong elevator too we did it we
did it we didn't take the wrong elevator we're good we got
this we got this we got this we got this how how we can't it
up now it's got to be the lag right yeah it has to be lag or
something else or or no anomaly um run around to see if we
lag at all or No lag.
Oh, wait.
I don't like this because we don't...
We don't know.
Oh, I don't like this.
It's not lag.
It's too much of a mystery.
This is a mystery.
Labels.
The labels are fine.
I'm looking at the calendar.
Yeah.
Medical center first.
We care about your health.
May, June, July.
There's no 666.
No.
Nothing with the table, the bed.
History, disease, history.
The x-rays.
There's no x-rays.
Nothing with the x-rays.
They all look the same the walls aren't smiling this time I
don't like this man.
I don't like this.
Yeah, we got the wall the wall was the first one we got
Yeah, the x-rays are okay.
There's no 666, I think I think we're
good.
Okay Okay.
I'll press the button.
I'll take the...
Oh, okay.
You take the blade.
We pressed it to...
Wait, what?
Oh!
So this is the...
We don't have to do this!
Oh, yep.
I lagged.
I'm lagging in the elevator.
This is it.
This is it!
Good luck, Mitt.
Oh.
We're at the...
Oh, we're at the floor.
What floor are we at?
666!
We're here.
Here we go.
Just run for it.
Wait, the elevator's not open, though.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Oh, I think something is going to come from that elevator.
Wait, no, but then like...
Oh, I think we need to turn around.
I think we need to turn around.
I think we need to...
Oh, what the hell?
Was that a PNG?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, that was a PNG.
This way, oh, the sheet goes, the sheet goes.
It's your cousin, it's your cousin.
It's my cousin's.
Just run!
Just, oh, it's the body bag, it's the body bag.
It's just a normal guy.
It's Anita.
It's a normal guy.
Oh my god, it's a normal guy.
Oh my god, no!
How did you die?
I don't know.
I think we have to like, as soon as it starts ringing, we
gotta, we gotta turn around.
Oh, that's true.
Wait, that means he's faster than us.
That's messed up.
There!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Turn around, turn around, turn around.
Turn around, turn around.
We wasted too much time.
Go, go, go.
Let's go, don't stop.
Just don't look back.
Don't look back.
Don't look.
I'll punch you.
I'll punch you if you get too close.
Okay, okay.
Punch me.
Punch me if you get too close.
Normal guy, normal guy.
Normal guy.
You're doing normal things.
Oh my God.
Are you punching me?
I'm punching.
Yes.
It's not my thing.
I'm doing my best oh it worked it worked it worked it worked
Don't die don't die don't die Oh my God Oh my God he was
right there he was right there oh my god is right behind us
Ah
Complete normal mode is what it said oh my god It was a
Doctor He wanted to get paid i like how this entire critics
is this one guy this one market manager developer youtube
anomaly acting school six six six six oh i know what we're
playing next oh my god wait are we going to classroom six
how are you gonna do is it gonna be floor is there an easy
mode to this like yeah there the easy mode is that there's a
routine so like every like uh oh wait what wait we're still
here it said i got an achievement too that was just like you
escaped the hospital but have you really is this hard mode
more oh my god the blood is like but like what is the hard
what what's the difference i don't know what's the
difference meant i don't know i don't know just keep going
just go to the next go to the elevator it says exit going on
i thought it's back to zero no no it's fine it's fine we're
fine we're okay it's all good it's all good oh no i don't
understand what would be different i think the game is over
i think the game's over too i think i think there's a return
to menu button that we are allowed yeah yeah i yeah i see it
too i see it you see that menu oh my god I got I got into
the elevator and the return to menu button showed up.
Oh my god, me too.
Yeah.
Wait, I'm in the menu.
Oh, you left?
Oh my.
No, it like showed up.
She's gone, you guys.
She's gone.
I'm going to the next floor.
You're going to the next floor.
Are you actually?
There's like a giant handprint.
What are these?
Giant.
Oh, what are you?
Is that you?
That's me.
how did you do that wait how did you do that you were over
there they're both orange they're both orange light which is
the og no they're not that one's only one that's orange that
one's orange for me i think you i think you messed up i
think you messed up the light yeah i think you messed it up
everything is like light now it's so bright this this has to
be the hard mode right so let's go to the menu i'm gonna go
to the menu and see if it's the hard if it's unlocked it has
to be the hard mode okay i'm returning to me like what's the
hard mode though let's see new game oh yeah it's hell return
to floor zero zero zero if you fail oh it's the same it's
just that you go back to zero okay so we finished we beat
the game wait is this actually but is it it basically like
instead of returning back to like uh like you know instead
of returning back to like 400 for 200 points to 300 it goes
back to zero yeah but is it also different floors too i
don't think so i'm starting a new game are you fucking i'm
curious go some balls is it bloody no it's bloody it's
bloody it's bloody so yeah the hard mode is the bloody mode
okay yeah yeah i would assume it is We did it.
We beat the game.
It only took us four hours.
What's the speedrun of this?
Speedrun.com.
It took us less than four hours.
You're right.
Because we had one hour of setup time.
Yeah.
One hour of setup time.
And also, it's not been four hours yet.
It's been not yet.
It's been one week since we...
Wait.
Oh my god.
We can be in the... We can get in.
There's only we should submit our runs to speedrun.com.
There's only two participants.
Yo, we're gonna be at the leaderboards.
We're gonna be at the leaderboards.
First place is the creator.
Stop.
I think that's cheating.
That is actual cheating.
I like how first place is the creator.
How was this time?
What's this time?
30 minute, 34 minutes.
That's not fair.
That's not even fair.
Oh, I know it's not the creator.
It's so much.
Other guy.
I messed up.
It's not the creator.
I thought it was the creator because I saw Hong Kong.
So I just because I know that Dev is from Hong Kong.
But what if it's maybe then it's a friend and he like fed
the answers.
You're right.
It was one month ago.
We could be the third and fourth place.
If I submit first, I get third place.
Oh my god, Doki.
The creator of that background just followed me on Twitter.
The laundry man.
I'm going to like the laundromat.
Go get the laundromat.
In fact, I'll follow them back.
You have to use the laundromat now.
You have to.
When will we get...
How did they know?
Meaning that ghost girl at the laundromat roleplay?
ASMR.
I will get the laundromat.
I'll get the laundromat.
what background everybody where will we get laundromat asmrp
i'm a maid i belong in the laundry room oh god oh i'm tired
this was fun this was fun and it was a team effort with the
wisp and the dragoons working together the wisp goons team
effort team effort we all did this together good job
everybody good job good job drag give yourself a pat on the
dragon oh especially the wisps helped like crazy crazy
amounts yeah yeah even though like mint didn't believe you
sometimes dragoons like the hole in the bed oh yeah you know
but i know doki like kind of doubts you guys all the time
but it's okay it's okay no wait i always believe
I don't know.
Good job, every wisp.
Good job, every dragoons.
You guys did it.
Remember to timestamp whoever gets the most correct, guys.
Okay, whoever gets the most correct, then what is it?
What do we get?
What do we have to do?
We have to...
What's the punishment?
I don't know.
Okay, we decide the punishment later.
Oh, that's right.
you want to decide only if you know huh oh are you not
confident are you not confident that you're gonna win no i'm
pretty confident i'm pretty confident i think i'm good
pretty confident yeah i need to decide something right now
then if you're so confident you're the one who was just like
well decide later yeah because like because we don't know we
don't know the result if you're so confident and figure out
something now loser has to use the other person's gamer
let me grab let me buy the free pack the free sample pack
oh no oh cheese cheese guys everybody are you gonna chat
with your wisp because i'm just gonna head off i think i'm
trying just a little bit but yeah not very much okay there
you go cheese man Cheers!
Bye bye!
We did it!
I just wanna chill for a second before we before we before I
leave you all I just wanna chill for just a second just a
little bit oh I'm missing hold on give me a second give me a
second
There we go.
Let me put on some BGM.
Just for a second.
That was, oh my god.
My brain is mush.
Every day this week.
Every day my brain has become more mush as I continue
onwards.
I think.
Oh god.
Oh, I don't know what song to put on.
Hold on.
Whisper goons are the real winners tonight.
I hope you guys enjoyed that.
Happy to report I have zero brain cells after that.
Me too!
I literally feel like my head is just like actually mush.
Oh my god.
That was fun though.
Choo!
Thank you!
Bantor.
Thanks for the Kalam.
Thank you.
My throat hurts.
Thanks for lining up my week.
Thank you.
Thanks, Virgil.
I hope you guys enjoyed that as an end to your week.
Happy Friday, everyone.
Koval, thanks for the vibe gifted.
Thank you, thank you.
That thinking part is the problem.
You should try stopping.
Of course, of course.
Yeah.
The obvious answer here is never trust Doki's game choices.
But yeah, I'm going to head out.
I will see you guys later.
Tomorrow for Metal Gear.
I will be playing up until Doki's new skin suit reveals, so
you can look forward to that.
But for now, I'm going to head out.
and happy friday mint thank you thank you guys thank you
thank you it's been four hours so um yeah got my postcard in
the mail today yeah thank you yes my gamer code my my my
gamer subs code everybody save 10 on actually um before i
before i i they actually contacted me so long ago they were
like do you want to become a gamer subs partner and i was
like um let me i've never had gamer subs before so like let
me have it before i try it because um i've I've tried...
What's the word?
I've tried...
Uh...
Skip ads.
Shut up!
It's my first sponsor, please!
Let me have my first sponsor, please.
Um, I've tried, like...
And I mean this legitimately.
I've tried, like, other... What's the word?
Other, um...
Those, like, other, like, gamer-themed, like, powdered
drinks and the last one i had which i never got a
sponsorship for but i tried it because a friend was
sponsored by them and i got it and like it was not i didn't
like it at all it was so grainy and so bad but this one i
actually liked so i was like oh well i don't mind because i
wanted to try it before i was like i'm gonna promote it to
you guys so you know i where I was like, you know, because
what if I tried it?
And I was like, ew, this is so bad.
Powdered energy drink stuff is hit or miss.
It can be very, very miss.
Yeah.
What flavor do you recommend?
I like mixing the mango and the raspberry, but they're both
non-caffeinated.
So, hmm.
But they sent me a ton of things.
They were like, which ones do you want to try?
So I got to try.
I was like, oh, I want to try mango.
I want to try raspberry.
I want to try the anime thigh.
and they sent me a bunch of like their um the the the
nutritional bars too and some of the ramen but i haven't had
any of the ramen it's all in my i keep looking over to the
left because it's all sitting there in a box um but yeah but
um i so you can guarantee that i at least tried it before
i'm before i'm selling it to you guys and i do like the
flavors i'm not gonna i'm not gonna try and sell something
to you guys that i think is shitty so um i'm not gonna just
try and get my bag you know so mint sale of approval buy
with confidence yeah i will turn down something if i think i
don't like it so and i mean that for like i guess any kind
of sponsor I've already had all of it.
It's good.
Yeah.
I think so too.
I haven't tried.
I'll be honest.
They sent me the chocolate peanut or the chocolate bars and
the peanut butter bars.
Oh, no, I have had the peanut butter one, I think.
I think it was kind of sweet.
Consume gamer subs.
Happy you got a sponsor.
Me too.
And I have more cool stuff on the way as well.
with um with a company yesterday with japanese company that
reached out to me and um at first i was like nervous i was
like should i i was like i don't feel confident enough in my
japanese to to to contact them but i hired a translator
actually and um so i had the meeting last night and uh i
hired the translator to help and um i asked them i was just
like have you worked with any western vtubers before and
they were like no you would be the first so so i'm kind of
excited about that actually i've been drinking gamer subs
for like two weeks straight my blood is gamer subs and now
you can use my code yubby so um yeah there's some cool
things happening when are they releasing mince thighs as a
flavor if i ever get a flavor I already have an idea, but
I'm not gonna tell you guys.
Not yet.
I don't know if I'm getting a flavor yet, so...
Um, yeah.
Okay, but yeah, so I am trying to plan stuff.
I am trying to do stuff.
It's just a little slower because it's just me.
You're pretty good at this whole VTuber thing.
I'm trying!
It's hard, um, but, you know.
Did you tell the Japanese company to use Code Boomer?
Stop.
Ugh.
Stop trying to guess my, I think, actually, I don't think
any of you would guess my flavor.
That I want, at least.
I drink multiple bottles of the red raspberry per night.
Every night, it's a problem.
They actually, they have, like, new ones that are kind of,
like, I think, I don't think they have, it says they have no
melatonin but it's supposed to help you it's supposed to
help you sleep so I don't know maybe I'll try it bool buff
flavor, boolberry actually that's so cute corn soup energy
drink that's what the world needs a corn soup flavored
energy drink mince flavor ecto cooler pretend the hammer is
a head pat why you guys want a head pat emo so bad i should
commission some more emotes i'll be honest i haven't
commissioned any but um okay i'm gonna head out because
tomorrow is um quite a long day as well and i have i have
early stream so i will see you guys tomorrow for battle gear
i was so excited okay thank you guys for the long stream
Today, longer stream, at least.
And I will see you guys tomorrow!
Otsumito!
Otsubasten!
See you guys later.
Have a good night!
And if I don't see you this weekend, have a great weekend.
And yeah!
Otsumito!
Ojo-y-sama!
Bye-bye!